you know what they improvise so let me
put the words there
i'm an island boy
trying to make my people proud
first minute
this has to be the clean version first
minutes oh yeah because they dropped an
bomb yeah well um i was assuming you
wouldn't say that but the any bombs
of any kind no no letter bombs of
anything island boy trying to keep it
they could stay like a lion they just
say weird [ __ ] like that oh i said i
said that s word
[Applause]
girl
[Laughter]
so okay i gotta say i love the island
boys song
but i like it the unplugged version oh
for sure um
love the jordan pencil clip
sorry everybody but oh yeah it's too
funny sorry you're what you're doing is
because you're not here because i'm not
here the whole week yeah
love the high segment thank you so good
job everybody yeah lots of
time remarks for
reviewing the week because it's been a
long week you know we make four episodes
a week here folks that ain't easy
two to three hours a piece
we out here grinding that sigma that's
sigma grind yep
and uh yeah the hi the uh guess who's
high video went over great from from
yesterday great job to everybody
how's everyone recovering anyone got a
hangover like someone like a b for
example who doesn't smoke that off
no i'm good i just i haven't rewatched
the segment
i'm just why i'll put it on right now
it's not that bad yeah it's all
very wholesome
i get it though i don't like watching
myself oh he i said something about
making a short film i don't know oh yeah
that was funny
the [ __ ] you guys gave me hasn't worn
off so like i still feel weird right now
you know you feel you feel uh what is it
called uh
washed out or what do they call it perma
high when you have a hangover from
smoking weed it's burnout i guess
yeah
or weak
lame weak
tired beta beta
thank you
thank you dan
yeah so honey sponsoring us today
um we tried to get the island boys on
but what happened because love you were
in contact with them but then they ended
up on [ __ ] pork but dave pork boys
pod unbelievable
what's up with that love
yeah i don't know
they're hard to contact i guess they're
doing island boy stuff
they're busy
did you tell them to contact us you i
mean i saw you told them you'll come on
the podcast like how do we get a hold of
them
yeah i think we might maybe we maybe i
told them to that we were going to
contact them i don't remember honestly
damn i can't believe dave got him first
that's some [ __ ] but they must have
like recorded that the same night
because that was up
i don't know they've been everywhere i
don't know
yeah you think so
busy boys
yeah is that island boys
[Music]
i'm a just island
boy i'm gonna
[Applause]
hey gabe
[Applause]
how you doing on this beautiful friday
[ __ ] baby
[ __ ] yeah baby doing some painting
activities no stuff no audio no work
there you go now
what's up
what are we doing out here
doing some artwork for
hell yeah what do you what are you um
painting
painting a picture like a human
and then a message like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] no way
[Applause]
that comes out of the bottom and it
smells really bad what is it called
that's called uh [ __ ] i believe okay
i think that's the word you're looking
for
well hold on let me analyze that some
more because there's some there's some
artistry there too
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
is that a girl it looks like a girl
that's pooping
right
it could be it could be it's unisex
[ __ ]
what you doing uh what you doing this
weekend any big plans i mean there's no
school no work right no so probably
probably
chilling with the family maybe have a
barbecue have a family outing or
something like that
smoke a couple cigars and some steak
hey let me ask you this i just thought
of something do you do cameos on the
weekend
sure oh so you do work on the weekend oh
dude well it's kind of like my own time
so i can do that i can enjoy my weekend
and do my cameos at night or early in
the morning something like that okay
still enjoy my so we're gonna put an
asterix next to the no work for you it's
no work with a little bit of a asterisk
is that okay
yeah yeah but there's
no work
at night only
all right well you have fun thanks for
drawing us that i love that maybe maybe
we could get that and frame it can we
can we get our hands on that is it for
sale zach reach out and purchase that
from you yeah let's go let's get that we
will hook that up yeah we're getting the
first white clay black clogged artwork
can you sign it for us
yeah sure yeah okay great so zach's
gonna come by and pick that up we're
gonna frame it
sure thanks buddy we love that i love
that all right have a great weekend
baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice doing a little art brush
very cool
that's hot that's some good art
[Music]
uh so anyway
um
well we get to at least watch the island
boys on dave pork boys show which is
better than nothing
more compromise
i don't know
but i'm jealous of love's uh intimate
relationship with them i'm sure they
would have if
i mean if they go live again and you
come knocking they'll probably let you
in well i follow so i follow them on
tick tock
here maybe i can make a connection right
now live i followed them with tick tock
and their account is
so good dude
they're posting all so much good [ __ ]
see don't follow me let me just follow
them on instagram
they said see that they don't how am i
supposed to get a hold of these guys
i'll just message him cold
yo come on our show we love you your
island vibes
[Music]
they have beautiful voices and what did
you think we had a whole debate about
like
does is it good or is it it's kind of
good i was listening to it and i was
like i'm not gonna lie it's kind of good
like
they changed the like
the rhythm
quite a bit we actually have um some
analysis about that well let's just pull
it up since we're on the topic yeah
here you guys we've been thinking and
talking about the island boys so much
everybody's been singing it here
backstage
and
one of the fupa troopers out there
did an analysis
of their flow and rhythm
and these guys are genius musicians
these guys are on the par of the likes
of miles davis the way that they
improvise switch up the beats absolutely
here you can see
an analysis do i give a shout out to uh
squid blue absolutely an analysis of the
beats per minute and how it switches up
i mean classical pianist can't even keep
up with this oh no way because on my
island so this is 4 4.
three four i i'm gonna
which is interesting yeah i have no idea
what we're looking at
yeah this
how do we know that they just are really
bad at keeping a tempo versus being
genius the lion
definitely gets blurry um when it comes
to you know
cutting-edge jazz like this so
well island jazz progressive island
progressive island jet yeah right
they're the tool of their uh like i feel
like we could confidently say miles
davis knows what he's doing
right you have to know the rules to
break them is the thing and i i think
they went to juilliard i heard right
yeah i believe so i definitely believe
it island uh i think the island bottom
line if you enjoy it then they know what
they're doing if you don't enjoy it
i like that
can you grab that right here
watch this i'm an eyeliner i put my
vests on yeah like
this is the new fibonacci sequence right
oh
do you think it's all built off
absolutely the golden sequence yeah
yeah here's a clip of them freestyling
on uh dave's
[ __ ] dave dude that my rivalry my
rivalry with dave deepens
apparently nobody cared though he only
got a hundred thousand dude island boys
we get you so much more views than that
why you waste your time with these low
low lives no relevance
i like this thing he likes to ride okay
oh no they're coming in this
can we get them in the studio that's
what i want um
i'll fly them out first if you fly them
out maybe they'll go for it
i'll fly them they probably have a lot
of opportunities can you imagine they're
like on a plane though to be honest with
that hair
oh they probably perform best while on
the island
do you think they wear masks or no
would they cause a fuss on an airplane
probably hard to say
hard to say
i think they would appreciate the
opportunity i'll fly them out i will i
was talking to ian i was wondering how
they shower with hair like that well
man it's not just like anyone with like
uh
yeah i don't think it's that complicated
yeah well i'm
yeah
i'm surprised ian didn't know that yeah
ian what's your problem i said i said
but you know whatever sure who brought
it up uh zach
yeah you did okay that makes sense
definitely and then what did ian say
he's like i don't know that's not what
happened
that is not what happens
i said you just you can shower you just
you know like
you cover the hair you shower
right
sure okay
interesting okay well
wow the island boys are tearing us apart
fight fight fight fight
freestyle game we're gonna put up
pictures of two different things it's
like random stuff and you guys can sing
you can rap so you just see what you
guys come up with
all right i love this i don't like this
they're not your toys to uh
to amuse you
oh put up a graphic of a duck rap it's
like i'm sorry these are the island boys
who the [ __ ] are you again
some stool
podcast yeah a stool there yeah what is
with that logo
it's a bar stool is the name but why
is there a meaning to that yeah because
they're like bars i think they like uh
they started as like a sports thing so
it's like a at a bar you would sit on a
stool and just aesthetically i don't
know that i would want a stool well you
know what else stool is
[Laughter]
seriously guys what are you uh
trying to be like the breakfast club
right we got kodak
bananas and tick
tock do we pick one or we do it in order
whatever you want however you want to do
it just try to incorporate the three or
if you can only do two whatever you can
come up with
hey i'm on tick tock with my damn glock
why you seen it with nobody i'ma rock it
like a damn song playing with nobody
with a glitzy you gonna play another you
gonna put that butt a stop and you blow
up on this top i'm gonna do it how you
seen it like oh boy you've seen us rock
i'm like damn you seen it though like
you seen it with this sauce i'm like
damn i got money i got sauce i'm like
damn i keep on boxing with that dirty
rhino clip i'm on tick tock back when
you seen it
trying to get it to the top [ __ ] i've
been on a mission i don't think you
understanding better start to sneak this
and hit you with the glizzy you can get
stopped
oh it is i thought it was a hot dog
originally it was a gun i know you do
i prefer i prefer life before knowing it
was a gun
i wish you didn't tell me that
top and that's your problem i don't
really worry about too many minutes
come on guys
i was in the field my young
just upsetting me that they're not on
our show doing that yeah right that
would be better
oh one
before we get i wasn't sure if you were
saying something okay
before we get too deep i want to
announce something very special going on
here
um we've been teasing this this is the
uh [ __ ] ryan cavanaugh [ __ ] trailer
drop
we did this is our first merch drop in
like years
not years yeah when's the last time we
used like a year a year it was like end
of last year we have three limited
edition t-shirts right here
um we've got the
this is basically all i'll explain this
is like obviously
this is just to help pay for the lawsuit
and obviously you know we don't need the
money it's just despite ryan this is
exclusive this is the spike drop yeah
this is the spike drop
larry's latte drop yeah oh that's a
great comparison like don't think like
don't buy it because you think that i
need the money buy it despite ryan yes
this is a community i want to show him
that you cannot [ __ ]
with the soldiers
and if he's trying to leave me dry
then uh we'll show him that our coffers
are
here govern yourself accordingly
as you remember that's what he famously
threatened me uh in the instagram
and here i am judge and he is [ __ ]
being sentenced
in a dramatic court drawing
that could be yours for
26.99 and then of course unrelated but
i feel like somewhat related
this is a play on the uh drake merch
right right
yeah this is fantastic stuff here
do you have your pass
yeah you got that did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
yeah and that's that's
that's fire merch the guy who called in
and sang that song
won the america's next america's next
talent yeah exactly this week so
congratulations
and then of course uh last but not least
uh
made by one of our great artists what
was his name again his name was manuel
manuel caraballo in collaboration with
tam you made a beautiful piece of art
that uh
we're commemorating here on the back so
if you want to stick it to ryan
cavanaugh and trailer
then please go to h3h3shop.com
which one of these you think is going to
be the hottest probably this one right
i don't know how wearable it is but
it's pretty epic
i i think the the one with the art is
the coolest uh just because i love that
piece so much but
uh
but i think you might be right i think
that the passport we'll see might do
pretty well yeah oh here uh the artist
just give him a little credit to want to
give him credit uh his name is
uh man
carbo here let me just put it up here
send me the link man
um
[Music]
yeah so h3shop.com thank you thank you
thank you thank you
all right let's send that to the caller
we sang there
the r kelly song we should sign a
sending one oh
centaur kelly no to the guy who's saying
oh can we send one to r kelly well
you can send them stuff in prison right
maybe yeah like i don't know charles
manson all these guys get fan mail all
the time
we should start mailing [ __ ] to r kelly
oh my god
just clowning on him when he's in prison
this is the artist shout out he's super
talented man
carballo
yeah this guy's awesome
cool
um so we've got a bunch to get to today
oh oh no
av just gave me an update r kelly is
unable to read fan mail due to him being
illiterate
oh
he actually yeah i've heard that he
can't read that's what these articles
that's actually just sad like that's
just a failure of our [ __ ]
that's just we failed as a society
that [ __ ] never learned to read
damn
okay let's not feel too bad for our okay
[Laughter]
um
let's see jamar this guy
we got an update you know you know this
guy jamari you were there who caught
who's called me a greedy jew
well he made an apology where he
basically
doubled down and was like well
being a jews uh greedy jews is actually
a stereotype that's true he literally
said that
right he said that
yeah interesting so that's on uh
research
he says i said that i don't know his
whole reasoning was super weird but
anyway uh cool shrek made him an award
a preview of the upcoming steamies
most anti-semitic apology
addressing the drama by jamari the same
video i went on to call ethan klein a
greedy jew when that's really what he is
and and i'm not trying to be offensive
but he's a greedy jew and i will say
that wasn't right okay i know it is kind
just a stereotype joke even admitted
that it is like the most common
stereotype that's actually true about
jewish people
you weirdo freak
what kind of weird [ __ ] are you putting
in my mouth [ __ ] psycho yeah i don't
think you said that
i was like
it uh
where i was
listen to you know how people call jews
greedy well that part is true but the
rest of the stuff
[ __ ] me
what
it is like the most common stereotype
that's actually true about jewish people
anti-semitism
straight
anti-semitic jew would you there's i'm
not trying to be offensive here there's
no way he's not like super anti-semitic
to make an apology video
that included that
so congratulations to him
award winner
stuff
millions of jews
did i joke somewhere or something like
that i i mean i don't know where he got
could have got that from possibly but
either way that doesn't make a
difference i mean to like bring it out
he's like i'm sorry i said jews agree i
called him a greedy jew but like even he
admits that jews are greedy
um we have an updated blunt rotation
because i i got mad that
did you see that they didn't even
include me in my own damn [ __ ]
subreddit
so what is this now oh great here we go
it's me
edited out every anybody but me
essentially what they're saying
great thank you guys
you really love me
yo did you see this uh keemstar made a
tick talk about me and it's so good no i
didn't
this is the best dude and you know i'm
gonna make a highlight about it he was
complaining about how much me and deaf
noodles talk about him
and uh and uh
ever okay let me just play it are you
tired of stalking me tired of constantly
watching my page from a fake account
talking about me to all of your friends
and simply just being a [ __ ] weirdo
then you need to call a psychiatric ward
because [ __ ] you're obsessed
dude he's so mad
he's so mad
his whole career is obsessing over
people yeah that's all he died that's it
especially me and deaf noodles and the
minute that like he can't handle it
he's so mad and this could be a
highlight for sure
and it's gonna be called our best
keemstar highlight and you know he's
watching it
hi keemstar you a [ __ ]
dear susan
oh no no
let's not get into that dear susan
today ethan mentioned me again
i'm not saying you need to ban him
but what i will say
is that
it's just not right
ethan got banned the last time i wrote
you ethan got banned for a week
why haven't you responded again
why won't you ban him against susan
i thought we had something special
i sent you a baggie of my beard hairs as
a token of love
i haven't heard back susan did you know
that my uh
the air right above my ass crack matches
my beard
and size and shape
i'll send you a bag of that as well
just please ban ethan
for another seven days i beg of you
send
okay now he's starting a new one dear
twitter
today death noodles made a new account
please shut down his twitter account
he's a very bad man unlike me
i'm a great man
please ban deafnose on twitter
this is his internal dialogue
this is the best thing ever
can we get that puppet out
oh my god no
no i don't think we should you think the
puppet's a bad idea i think it's a very
bad idea
never again
really yes i'm not gonna do anything to
it it's too far it's too far yeah you
want another strike you have to destroy
dan i told you the stripe wasn't because
of the puppet
we have a we have a rule
rule number one just govern yourself
accordingly listen to dan order of opera
if i listen to dan this show would be
normal
i don't think
i believe the puppet was why he emailed
the first time yes yeah well it didn't
get me banned though what got me banned
was talking about his uh
i didn't say anything i was saying
i don't know
anything about his
i don't know anything about his
situation
probably gotta okay i'm not gonna do it
i [ __ ] up
dear susan can we point out though that
when he scrolls through all of the
videos that he's watched every single
one
can we title this something about
because i know that it doesn't have a
title now let's do let's name it
something about keemstar
keemstar called me out
i guess that's relatively tame
you want to think of something keemstar
sent
keemstar sent me anthrax
keemstar
[Laughter]
keemstar has been a fan this whole time
you're casting him a drift in a sea of
slander and lies
okay let's watch you tired of stalking
me tired of constantly watching my page
let's see so let's let's analyze the so
he's is he watched he's watched some of
deaths for sure yeah the majority i mean
the but like also like all of it or well
this one's half
watching my page from a fake account
talking about me to all of you so let's
see friends and simply just
this one he watched all of which one was
that yeah i saw
one that was almost
full this one he watched we oh
that one was good yeah i'm glad he
watched that one
wait that one's really long too you need
to call a psychiatric ward he thinks i'm
obsessed with him that's my favorite
are you tired how about we name it
keemstar is obsessed with me
toss it back and he sent me anthrax
i think he watches every episode
i have been engaged with him on tv is a
biological terrorist
you want this keemstar [ __ ] i haven't
engaged with him on twitter and forever
but he blocked me randomly like a week
ago as after i shouted out death noodles
you find that interesting he blocked a
bee just a week ago about a week ago
yeah what a week or two yeah
pre-emptive block
i'm gonna beat her that's funny because
he was the one harassing you i mean i
thought he would have already blocked
you well he blocked me once when i had
like 100 followers
and then yeah he's weird like that he
blocks and unblocks yeah well because he
he'll block like
thousands of people and then everyone's
like dude you're such a snowflake
because he was showing off his block
list and he goes okay i'm going to
unblock everyone yeah and then he goes
and blocks a b for no reason
keemstar you're guilty of it
subscribe to def
love deaf noodles
anyway shout out to
memestar
killer meme star
suggestions on titles um keemstar
watches all my videos keemstar watches
oh we got oh yeah give me suggestions
from there is our biggest fan keemstar
is our biggest fan i mean it needs to be
more provocative than that
well what else we got in the title uh
let's see if i see more
i'm surprised he hasn't teamed up with
jamar yet to uh narrate mineconf
audiobook
i thought they'd be teamed up by now
so frustrating
[Music]
all right
well that's fun
um
we have the fleshly you remember the
fleshlight guy he's calling in today
and uh
someone from tiktok is calling in as
well an employee from tick tock
interesting to give us an inside scoop
they're calling it anonymously they've
proved their employment
[ __ ] awesome
but yeah just to update you guys on the
fleshlight dude we we watched him i
think last week he he he's got a new
drop
yo even on youtube he's crushing this is
three million views
this guy is an article i mean it's
silicone
um
gently used lightwear
um it has the ticklers you know often
times you'll see them and the ticklers
have fallen off or been you know you
know misused
but um yeah
here it is guys i mean that's the holy
grail don't sleep on that bad boy
yeah so he we're gonna get him to call
in this guy is a
true artist
we're actually up to 30 minutes so maybe
we should do the ads and while we're
doing that we can queue them up okay we
only have one ad so yeah let's get let's
set him up his name is malik
was lazari
the fleshlight guy
and um
i'm super excited to get into his mind
pick his brain a little bit
uh in the meantime let's thank our
sponsor honey
we all shop online and we've seen that
promo code taunting us
at checkout
but thanks to honey manual searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
car
it's bugs
a little nap
don't fly my mouth
honey is the free yep yep honey supports
over 30 000 stores online ranging from
tech gaming products and fashion brands
and even food delivery imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
then all of a sudden
when you're at checkout the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons you can
find for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon watch the price drop
immediately you don't even have to think
about it dude
you've saved a bunch of money on honey
help me up
tell me about that
um i shop and then when it's time to go
to check out i just always check the
honey thing
and sometimes it works you don't think
about it dude you don't have to think
about it dude
you don't have to think about it and
honestly it's so easy to install it's
like two clicks one added extension to
and that's it i mean they've saved
they've saved 17 million members over
two billion dollars you know
uh if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds and by getting it
you're going to be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast i
would never recommend
something i don't use and actually
i would never browse i would never shop
without honey installed
it's insane get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
h38d
that's joinhoney.com
h380 thank you thank you peace and love
this is a serious message
all right well while we wait for uh
the fleshlight guy
um
you let's watch the math teacher mock
native americans what is it this one's
pretty bad oh i saw she got in trouble
for this big time oh yeah this teacher
was recorded doing some kind of racial
native american i don't i don't know
what's the context of why she was doing
this oh because sokatoa is like a uh
trigonometry trigonometry like pneumatic
thing kind of like pet mess or whatever
yeah it's to find the
oh my god it's to find the i wrote it
down because i couldn't remember
definition of trigonometric functions
sine cosine and tangent what the [ __ ] is
that dancing yeah well because
well it doesn't but it vaguely sounds
like a native american name and so she's
trying to instill it into her students
by doing
yes oh so it's got nothing to do with no
oh so sohcahtoa
is a helpful num uh
mnemonic for remembering the definition
of tremendon tremen
trigonomic functions okay
soka noah i didn't say it that bad damn
yeah
so
katoa
anybody want to go
all right
what's so smart around here
um so
here
so
calto
heist yeah that's high school
this lady's unhinged forget about the
native american stereotype
i mean don't forget everybody but in
addition
well i'm much more i'm just concerned
this lady is like fully unhinged
how would how do you even do that in
front of a high school class i get to go
home
and there's more can i get all of my
feathers
[Music]
what
[Laughter]
[Music]
i kind of do things
she's just unhinged
it's going on for so long it's like we
get it i don't
delete me from this conversation
i mean that doesn't look like a teacher
also just not teaching anything right
over and over again i could easily see
she you could just put her in a straight
jacket yeah and a padded room and you
wouldn't notice the difference
she would fit right in there just as
well
more
water
water
[Music]
is she on something man please tell me
that's kind of like it i'll take what
she's having
yo someone's straight up filmmaker like
what is this yeah so she's from socal
this is right in our neck of the woods
really riverside baby oh riverside okay
and i'm pretty sure it was a native
american student who filmed this oh man
wow
man oh man
oops why is she calling so long rocks
where's my children
i pulled him out of my bathroom
anymore you're just taking the rock gods
like where'd the math go
yeah that was a wild ride man so what
happened to her she was executed
yeah no she's she's gone
she gone uh she has been put on leave i
mean this happened yesterday afternoon
so this is a relatively breaking
news there's a statement from riverside
unified school district saying they are
investigated she's been placed on leave
i
imagine but on the other hand none of
those kids will ever forget so so could
that help ever
so could tell either will i yeah
oh god yeah
yeah
guys can you brainstorm a title because
i don't like the generic
i'm not saying i don't like the generic
i'm obsessed with keemstar how about
that i'm obsessed yeah because that's
what he said that's what he's saying
about you well wouldn't it be funnier if
it was he's obsessed or maybe that's
obvious
i feel like that's obvious i'm obsessed
with it i am obsessed with keemstar i'm
coming out as a huge keemstar fan
oh i'm gonna sound bite the [ __ ] out of
that
back there brainstorm a little bit so i
don't have to talk about it on the show
because it would be nice to have a title
on it thank you you got a few
compliments today about what your fate
and that oh the food i've been growing
my beard out
usually i can't grow my beard up but
i've been like combing it
and trying to take care of it it doesn't
look that good it's so patchy i'm just
i'm i'm just such a shame
look how patchy
as long as i keep my head like this it
looks okay
but the minute i do this go ahead
i mean look at that what a disaster what
a beta i wish i could get mine to that
point
really it's like that it's like in this
area like who care about that area
anyway because it just looks weird every
time i raise my head it's like beta beta
oh i need to take some testosterone
injections to my bowls
yeah and this jacket and then um camstar
could probably spray paint or whatever
he does
yeah spray paint that's what he does
black
hair for man whatever yeah this is a um
teddy fresh corduroy jacket
that's coming out this month right yeah
and look at this the
little thing in the jackpot jacket
pocket matches my shirt unintentionally
how cool is that
yeah this is super nice
congratulations
[Applause]
um
[Music]
so let's get prepped for the fleshlight
guy yeah he's coming on in just a second
we'll we'll we'll do a little refresher
there you go oh so here's an apple pie
actually one that looks really oh god
american apple pie also referred to as
the cutie pie oh that's perfect oh no
well you know it's uh it's american
here we got the video
alexa
pause
all right guys i really thought i lost
this joiner here i'm super glad i found
it so i can show you guys
um
super rare joint you know
it's the classic cherry pie
uh
that's not glazing that's just super
fine detail i mean that's not what you
know that's just what it is
it's got the uh catcher's plate 10.
you know that was like a super rare
edition that you know they didn't really
release a lot of those
but as you know you know
this was made for uh executives on the
movie american pie so there's not a lot
of
um
these in existence
but
i mean
this is
as nice as they come when you do see
them and you never see them yeah in this
condition so uh yeah
don't
sleep sleep on it folks
go ahead
uh what's his name again malik
yeah so this is malik the american uh
hero
who makes basically artisan fleshlights
custom made
um
here's one of the singing fish that's
pretty um
hey
malik hey how are you i'm doing the
fleshlight god
you you're a collector of fine
fleshlights
yes a collector and i also restore them
oh you restore them
yes i think i get the chance he's coming
to us from inside a fleshlight right now
deep inside very neat
yeah so
so do you
when you make these do you try them out
just to see kind of if they're you know
built for
for speed or comfort
yeah not for free
you know what i mean i've been trying to
figure that out you know like an only
fans
it might really go
people might really want to see them in
use you know what i mean because like
when people were making so much money
off of only fans i was
like dang
[Laughter]
well that would be that that would
certainly be the next level
wouldn't it so what what you what's your
fa how did you get into uh this artisan
fleshlight game
well i made the first one which was like
the bug's life joint yeah that one's
great
great one right oh yeah
like
that one was actually like not
functional which oh no
hey you gotta you gotta go through the
process you know what i mean
it's a process you gotta figure it out
but
after that one just had like such a buzz
about it i i just knew that i had to
keep doing it you know what i mean for
the people
right
and so the but so do you ever sell these
because i feel like the bugs life you
said you're selling it for 2 000 did
anyone buy it
well that's like an interesting question
because like
i can't really sell them to the people
who want to buy them because
in that case they're not collectors you
know what i mean they'll end up in the
basement getting used and then they'll
like use to exist beyond that beyond
that basement you know what i mean
i would collect that i promise i won't
use it i mean you could use it but like
you know on a low key like gentle
yeah gentle like you can't like make you
well i mean i guess you could make an
only fans and start going to town on it
i don't know if that's like the best
case scenario yeah but the i mean i i'm
just super into what you're doing i
i think it's awesome that means a lot
yeah
so you started with the bugs life and by
the way what's going on so i've noticed
this phenomenon on tick tock where
a new channel is born and there's one
fleshlight uh review oh yeah and it goes
super viral
are the is the problem that tick tock
shutting down these are you making these
what's going on yeah no so like for
every you know flashlight that i find i
make a video you know just to let people
know hey found another grail
and here it is you know don't sleep if
you want it it's available
but the thing is is like tick tock has
banned me three times so i'm on my
fourth tick tock right and i don't know
uh how many lives i had do i have nine
lives do you have
four lives i don't know because if i
only have four i'm on my last leg buddy
you know what i mean right yeah
so but anyways people don't tag people
on tick tock i've noticed that like it's
just like not something that enters
their you know what i mean mental when
they when they post something because
you can just save a video and then just
go right to it
you know whereas instagram you're kind
of thinking you know maybe i should
credit this person or something yeah i
think it's just a v it's just becomes
like a video in the void
yeah exactly which is fine with me you
know at first i was like damn y'all
could hook me up with a little tag
but you know now it's like okay it's
it's going so hard that like i'm okay
with it stuff yeah so um there's i've
even seen up at this point i get all the
fleshlight videos because i love them
and watch them all but that's
interesting yeah but what's interesting
now is there's a whole uh subculture of
people complaining about getting all the
fleshlight videos
i love to hear the complaints i really
yeah
because the complaint department that's
me
yeah i'll take them all i love to hear
it and there's people like hey can you
please just end this already i'm like
i'm ready to die like
what's wrong with you
maybe they need a good round with one of
your collectibles who would chill them
out
yeah that's a funny thing too is like i
get a lot of messages
and they're all just like lowballers
tire kickers
sexual oblivion really what do they
offer
they offer like blow jobs
oh they offer favorite sexual favors
and also like i'm confused as to like
they're they're so late you know what i
mean
like you think if it was 200 it wouldn't
have already sold out right right
well so i'm i'm willing to give you top
dollar for one of these like i love the
beauty and the beast one that that one
to me is fantastic the candle oh the
mater d yeah the mater d
that's a low key sleeper hit right there
so maybe we can negotiate something like
i want to support the arts
what can you let that go for me for it's
on screen right now
ethan you're gonna have to hit me up on
a separate thread
we gotta talk negotiations we gotta get
in you're gonna hit me hard bro you're
gonna [ __ ] get my lawyers i gotta get
my lawyers my team lawyers involved okay
and then we gotta sit down my people
call your people
all right we'll tell you one thing
though yeah that one is haunted
oh [ __ ]
yeah that one's cursed
even better it's funny that you chose
that one because that one is absolutely
cursed i found it in a safe
whoa
whoa
i wonder if you're safe at a church
wow
in the pastor's office
in the pastor's office can you believe
it i don't believe it i'm gonna have to
get the catholic church
i'm gonna have to get this thing
exercised
all right i'll give you 2 000 bucks for
this straight up
cash okay you're talking original we're
talking inflation though yeah
[Laughter]
i mean since the original this is the
original you know vice article
it's been like a year okay have you got
any offers
all right so okay inflation what's your
inflation ten percent you know that's
that's a lot
yeah did you say fellatio no no no
all right we could talk we could try
special price nice price
5k 5000 wow okay that's an expensive
[ __ ]
you know inflation in 2020 was 1.25
so off at thousand dollars 5k let me
think about it hey buddy try to buy a
house in austin all right
and come talk to me
that's true this is good like a house
for my deck
and that's a good price if you think
about it like that
wait don't you already have uh
go ahead
house for your dick
well it's like a second home a vacation
home you know
yeah
everybody needs a cabin up north
exactly exactly
yeah so so what but what do you do
because i expect you're an artist you
work with your hands you're in some kind
of workshop there like tell me about
yourself a little bit
yeah um so i mean i went to art school
which is kind of like everybody's gonna
say that and that's like why they still
make art even though it doesn't make
money
you know
and then after art school i started
installing artwork so that's an
interesting gig like you know just for
millionaires billionaires i'm just like
installing like crazy pieces
you know i mean like a kusama above
somebody's sink
girl
they wash your hands and they're all
on the kusama like
like screw you money you know what i
mean yeah
so there's that and then also i do
production work in uh film and
television and stuff like that so
it's just always something different and
that's what i that's what i like to do
it's just something different every day
yeah shake it up every day you know and
that
being flexible with those kind of
jobs like gives me a lot of time to work
in this here studios you know
and make twisted creations
i love your art i genuinely do i think
you're hilarious
and the minute i saw this i was like
this guy's a real artist it wasn't even
just like jokes yeah this is real [ __ ]
it's really impressive actually i don't
know how you make those
yeah yeah okay what about the style
you're the style queen
what about it
you're the style queen
yes yes she is oh i'm just saying i'm
down with the fashion big time
fashionista myself so
i feel you big time on that level for
sure listen where should people go check
you out where do you want us we're going
to put links we're giving you shout outs
where do you want the people to go
all right you guys rock but like can i
just say
that i'd love for people to check out my
new country single hit country single
seriously sure just recorded it like you
i'll play it on there it's on it's on
every major
streaming night what do i type i'm on
youtube right now what do i tell all
right the artist name is buster cheeks
buster cheeks brush your cheeks and it's
called grand theft panty
rand theft panty
100 true story
whoops
wrote it myself and produced by david i
mean it's on youtube how bad could it be
all right let's go in and cold this is a
live show so i'm trusting you now
trust me
well hey run it run it to uh 30 seconds
okay amy's going to pre he's going to
pre-screen that just in case it gets too
slightly unless you want to unless you
want to run the whole thing i mean
that's i'll listen to the whole thing i
just want to make sure there's no like
uh you know oh no run the whole thing
then run it from the beginning there's
no n-bombs or something in this uh oh no
no no no non-explicit i don't even curse
yeah you don't curse okay no on a daily
basis i do not curse that's a good man
right there a man of god
hey
are you i am a pastor after all yeah
that's how you where you find all these
fleshlights hey by the way when you're
in these rich people's houses oh you
ever think like maybe hide one of those
fleshlights in there and just imagine
what they do if they found one of those
i mean what would you even do about that
i mean honestly i think that they would
be stoked because they realized like
what an investment they just like what a
windfall yeah
like wow i just came into like
more money than i already have yeah
you know what i mean
all right how do i keep getting hooked
up like this i don't know all right
buster cheeks grand theft panties on
youtube
okay on youtube so here we go
the grand unveiling everybody go show
some love
for malik uh les lazari how do you say
your last name lazy lazaree yeah malek
lazaree here we go well
there was this chick i was saying
and for one reason or another
borrowed pair of panties
i got my favorite panties and they [ __ ]
up on that cowboy hat on
i told her
you can borrow those pair of panties
on one condition
that you bring them straight back to me
as soon as you're done with them
she put them on and sure enough they
look great on her
but that don't change the fact
she took my
pair of panties right away from me it
was grand theft panties in the first
degree
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
obviously
[Applause]
that's a good old boy that i'll be
hearing that at the
rodeo
dude
um
the top comment on this i would like to
buy the shrek sludgehole all jokes aside
i would like to purchase it
you got like i don't know why i can't
hear myself
from you yeah
yeah all righty
so malik we're having audio issues
oh maybe you open a stream or something
i can hear myself
thank you buddy
all right all right well
well malik um
it's been a treasure to talk to you're
such a funny talented guy
i can hear myself
just muted zach yeah it's not working
sorry um m
lazarey on instagram
and you guys saw the youtube check him
out support him this is a talented man
he's going places i'm gonna have to have
a conversation with him uh
after the show about purchasing that uh
beauty and the beast uh candlelight
fleshlight
even though it is cursed thank you thank
you such a treat having you on the show
great meeting you take care all right
you be good keep grinding out there get
that sigma grind on get that sigma grind
on now
all right
thank you dude take care song was a
schlapper dude
yo that guy is a character just like i
knew he'd be yep no
great voice that was a banger that was a
real banger he should do comedy i mean
he's funny
yeah
it's like such it's like the funniest
thing ever what he's doing yeah
totally and the way he pitch it too like
he restores them he just finds them
so good
that would be a really good art show i
like i would legit go to that
bring the family and everything
he's totally a comedian though yeah
definitely
um
let's see what else we got we watched
the um
they're they want teddy flashlight oh
god
a teddy bear face flashlight yeah maybe
that is a good collab we could do
this is something that came up big
creators are still working with james
charles i don't [ __ ]
get this
right i don't get it
why are people working with james
charles why
that's like going and doing a collab
with r kelly at this point i mean maybe
a little less bad but
oh no what's the difference
honestly
how can you put james charles in your
video you sick
[ __ ] you really don't care all these
people faze rug what's up dude you don't
care that this guy's a preying on kids
on snapchat
phase rug pull
i think they just don't want to believe
it probably
they're probably well why even take the
chance then
they believe it how do you not believe
it
it's all there he admitted he said i did
it
sister he says i did it
let's see i'm not collaborating with him
i just feel like these people need to be
shamed because clearly they don't have a
[ __ ] brain and what they're doing is
they're rehabilitating james's
reputation because look
overwhelming like majority here these
people are all
enabling and rehabilitating a predator
straight up period
and they should be ashamed
good away from you bro is your foot
moving no baby
ben i'm so stressed all right lexie keep
it going green light red light all right
so face revs marcus cole and ben all
made it four more left you guys god dude
shut up
we did it first loser
yeah did you shoot them with paintballs
when they died
no
dude anyone here participating is a uh
predator straight up and eliminated it's
a team one air rack let's take a look
here
[ __ ] you definitely [ __ ] you
i mean this kid looks like he's like
16 i don't know but [ __ ] you this dude
uh definitely gonna i'm sorry faze rug
but i gotta drop you bro
i know you want to be friends with me
but you can't appear in a video with
james charles and then be my friend
marcus andrew fazer yeah all right so we
have team one and team two
hey wait wait who's gonna win we are
embarrassing yeah i don't know what do
you i mean what are you what's your take
on this it seems like super foul
you guys can me
anyone know any ps gallery yeah olivia
especially because you're in tune with
all this
i think it's stupid
well said thank you
it's deep
you can't keep getting away with it i
don't know it makes me sick
they're rehabilitating his thing and
this happened all the time it's just
like
it's easier to believe the
not bad
truth like people don't probably don't
want to believe it so
they probably take his word that i don't
know
some people lied yeah but i think i know
he erased the video but like i guess but
i guess being ignorant is an excuse like
if you look at these big predators
throughout history like take for example
woody allen all these accusations came
out and then people keep working with
him giving him awards and enabling him
further you could say the same thing
about roman polanski you could say the
same thing
r kelly r kelly yeah i mean even to an
extent chris brown who beat the [ __ ] out
of rihanna and people are all
rehabilitating them and enabling them to
do it again i mean this is [ __ ] because
i guess they're too cowardly to either
make a stand or because they know that
you know it's a clout bomb having james
charles in the [ __ ] video but dude
you this guy is a predator
you're tugging you know what you're
tugging here little kids into his dms
here let's get a shot of these dudes
aiding and assisting james charles uh
metaphorically
here
hi hi james i'm 16. can i send you a
picture of my dick oh they just pulled
that dick right into his dms that's what
they did congratulations you officially
lost but how does this slime feel pretty
satisfying you guys are the winning team
how do you guys feel we did it i mean
like i said
look it's not even
that much of a clout gain at this point
anyways i mean it has a lot of views
yeah but i think this guy usually gets a
lot of views i just i mean
there are 10 youtubers they could have
easily done it without them
certainly faded from where it was a year
or two ago because of all this so
i'm just saying it's even
not even that good yeah you're not
you're not benefiting from having them
in your video necessarily
yeah i don't know this [ __ ] is just
disgusting freak [ __ ] dude isn't it
oh sorry no you're good good luck also
face rug only has children watching him
like literally his whole fan base is
below 18. that's what i was going to say
too oh well there you go that's right
that's disturbing i mean it's really
it's freak [ __ ] i don't know how to
describe it i mean probably all these
people have like fairly young fans
take a seat right over there
and um it's disgusting
freak behavior i don't know what's to
say these people are all just freaking
disgusting i mean it makes me sick
it makes me sick
what are you doing
why are you doing this
it's unforgivable it's a crime against
humanity what are we going to do
the chances that one of your kid
followers don't end up in james charles
snapchat is basically zero percent at
this point
you know out of the seven million
watching
you know was it worth it for the extra
500 000 views
brent riviera
yeah i just did a lie detector test it
checks out
i don't know
that's good maybe that could be a good
title uh people are enabling james
charles and keemstar is obsessed with me
that's great that sounds great that's my
sister snapped
we'll make it happen dan don't worry
they're rolling your eyes
come on now
you can stop talking about it
thank you one winner let's meet the
youtubers
my name's sophie dossier ben azaler i'm
andrew davis
this game is red light green light my
sister like
yeah makes me want to [ __ ] and piss
and stomp my feet
um
oh and then so next up we have a
tick-tock moderator calling in i'm gonna
pick their brain they're calling it
anonymously at great risk to themselves
they are modern day edward snowden
[Laughter]
are they ready to call in by the way
yeah and we're going to get them
quick questions
yeah okay i got a p2 quick update malik
said thanks for having him on and the
reason the audio was messed up was
because that banger blew out the
speakers
yeah yeah i totally get that
they took my dirty panties and she took
them to them
i tried to get my panties back but she
wouldn't give
and i said
shippy yeah yeah yeah like the dirty
panties what
with the skin marks in the way
skippy yeah yeah yay
get along little panty
till the fart stains spray
oh jesus
uh um so they'll be on in a second do
you want to um just in case anybody
isn't caught up on the show give some
context to what's going on with your
tick tock yeah so
basically tick tock keeps [ __ ]
erasing my content like immediately like
they clearly like in the first 10
minutes it goes down three of my last
four tick tocks were removed my last one
here i'll just pull it up we talked
about it briefly
not to go in on trisha again but it's
just
un kind of unfortunately related to her
um
oh thank you baby this tweet kind of
explains it
yeah so
like trish there was a compilation going
viral of trisha
making fun of my tourette's
and i posted a reaction to it just me
watching it right
removed for hate speech you know against
myself
and
three of my last four videos
have been removed for hate speech what
the [ __ ] i just i can't make content
there because somebody removes my videos
and it's not like after a day it's in
the first 10 minutes
so somebody wrote in and said yo i work
on the tick tock moderation team i want
to call in anonymously
and you know
give you some intel so this should
actually be really interesting to figure
out see what's the inner workings like
back there
i gotta pee all right you carry the show
either oh
um
how about i show you how big i am
i mean
oh crazy
it's getting wild
i feel like it's going now like on fast
forward like does it feel the same as it
did with theodore or you feel bigger or
smaller
um
i don't know i feel like it's it's
nicked up on me like all of a sudden
it's like whoa oh okay i'm almost like
gonna finish second trimester soon and
then it's like
last trimester is crazy it's like
just the end
time flies yeah
um so i don't know i feel like at the on
the first pregnancy it's just everything
is so new so it's like you're always
thinking about it but now it's just kind
of in the background so
it's um
it is different in some ways
and also we still have theodo to take
care of so it's like
the first one it's all about me because
i'm pregnant now it's like yeah i still
gotta do everything and be pregnant
does it feel like you guys don't have
two kids or four kids because the dogs
as well they're sort of like oh my god
i mean
and
i have ethan too
it's hard like we
we're we're still trying to potty train
theodore
and um i feel like ethan is like so
he just wants he is really soft with
theodore sometimes so it's like he just
wants to give him what he wants and like
tiro just wants the diaper
and so i'm telling ethan it's like i
need to potty train you too because it's
i have to be the bad one that's like no
diapers
but
um
yeah some people in the chat are asking
for update on theodore how he's doing in
general still um
like half half i would say sometimes
he's back to normal but then in the
evenings it seems worse lately
i don't know
it's not fully back to himself yet so
we've had a rough two weeks i would say
and
crazy thing just this so this whole week
he almost didn't go at all to his school
thing because he wasn't feeling well
and then this morning they just told us
that there's a covert case in his class
oh that's scary yeah
so
pretty wild
hello
are you ready to speak to this uh
to our mole i actually have an update
yeah bring them on but so here i'll send
you a screenshot so you can put on the
screen i appealed the hate speech one
right and i got an update here on the
appeal
there's definite corruption going on
behind the scenes it says it was
determined that your content violates
applicable laws
laws and cannot be restored for hate
speech
look i sent it in the chat
it says it my content i didn't say
anything i silently watched
yeah
you've never take talks like that before
where you just kind of watch
and make
face reactions yes and mine always gets
taken down and the original stays up
look at this
look
your content violates applicable laws
and cannot be restored
but the original is still up somebody
explained this actually we have someone
to explain this
so what what oh we don't we're not
saying their name
they are our anonymous source
and uh i believe they're here can you
hear us
yep i can hear you guys
anonymous source has come to us at great
risk
to herself
how are you guys doing today are you
scared to be calling in are you afraid
that they're going to suss you out
i mean just like a little bit because um
you know when you do
uh work for tick tock you do have to
sign an nda
we offered a voice changer but you
declined it i want to say for the record
but
i don't think they'll track it and trace
it back to you i think we're going to
work hard to protect your identity at
all costs
no that's that's perfectly fine with me
yeah and if they do identify you we can
really relocate you to russia where
snowden is currently living to keep the
government from getting to you i'm just
telling you good on that we'll go to all
lengths to protect your identity
so so what is your job in tick tock
so i am a content moderator so um
literally all day i'm just watching tic
tocs and uh kind of moderating them and
basically just going through videos that
have already been either like reported
or like our ai system has already
automatically detected that something in
the video has triggered it that shows
that it broke either community
guidelines or
with either like the image or audio
and then i kind of just review it myself
manually
got it so there's two ways content comes
across your desk either the algorithm
says yo there might be something wrong
with this or it's getting mass reported
and it goes to your desk and then you
say oh this isn't violation or it's not
exactly
now how is it first of all you must see
some crazy [ __ ]
oh no definitely so one thing that i do
kind of like whenever i do discuss work
so they actually have to have like
wellness counselors available to you
because you do see some pretty
um crazy stuff like i've seen i've seen
it all
probably like gore
sexual oh like some isis cartel
beheadings oh lee that is like animal
abuse sexual contact dude stuff like
that so much animal abuse it's it's and
and what happens because sometimes i see
straight up animal
torture
and it has like
600 000 likes i reported every time
they just keep showing it to me but it
stays up does that mean that somebody's
reviewed it and been like that's safe
um not always sometimes it gets it gets
reported but sometimes what people do
so there's times where like a viral
video like there is a viral video of a
guy who had taken his life on facebook
live and it constantly kept just getting
re-uploaded and what people were doing
it would be like a cute here's a cute
video of a cat and then like three
seconds five seconds in it just like
shows you like the glory con content oh
and so they would like bait people into
like watching thinking you're watching
some cutesy video and the next thing you
know there's a guy blowing his head off
oh jesus [ __ ] christ bro
yeah that's rough work honestly
yeah so that's why they have to have
like wellness counselors and stuff like
it's like a weekly thing that we'll see
like wellness counselors and kind of
like discuss thankfully it's not been as
often
um
as it has been before but
yeah it can get pretty graphic
so let me ask you is that
is that uh
worse than or better than my sitting
silently and watching trisha
oh no no no i'd take you i take your
reaction silently uh watching trisha any
day so can you explain to me how it's
possible that like every it seems like
almost every video i post within the
first 10 minutes it gets removed for
something like hate speech
so now just with your video for example
so i i've actually sent your video to a
few higher ups um because i was confused
because so the original video it would
make sense to me for it to be removed um
so it doesn't make sense that your video
was removed but not the original video
because the original video even though
it is just a compilation and it's not
like the user itself who are making
these comments that trisha was making
um it still would be considered hate
speech because
um you know she's you know making fun of
like i guess we could consider you a
protected group making fun of your
internet thank you so um yeah um that
would be taken down so typically like we
even have a queue of videos when we're
moderating of just duets now even if you
or the person who's dividing the video
is not uh breaking the community
guidelines we would still remove the
video because obviously right next to it
the video like i said like trisha's is
is breaking policy so both would have to
be removed so i did ask them um you know
why would this be removed and they said
um
that it should be removed and i asked
basically if um
i'm looking for the exact quote because
of what he said because i was like i
asked basically if there's any kind of
favoritism going on
um with certain creators and they said
uh
let me look they said that they um
it was a broad question
uh that i was asking and that they don't
want the full details on it but
different creators are moderated a
little bit differently so i do think
some people
um do have somewhat of an advantage or
kind of go disadvantaged in my case
yeah disadvantage in your case
unfortunately and i do think that you
were um unfairly
uh your video was unfairly removed but
yeah some people are go a little bit
more under the radar
actually what's interesting as well is
that ours wasn't even a duet we had
because the the she or the original
creator of the compilation turned off to
it so we had to edit it
to make it look like a duet
so but that's the thing i i don't know
what's up but they yeah can you see any
like flags on my account or anything
like that or you don't have access to
that don't have access so the way like
any videos come onto my um
to my desk basically uh they're already
like the ai system has either
already automatically detected it or we
have like a queue where videos have been
reported now i can look at um i would
have to have like an actual video id but
obviously that's not even something you
can get but we are able to see what um
certain moderators were flagging the
videos because when a video gets
moderated it actually goes through three
rounds of moderation so about three
moderators will look at a specific video
and then there is another department who
has like the 100 final say um the
quality control will you know determine
whether this video is going to be
taken down but even in
several instances i've seen videos where
we've had to appeal them because quality
control is not on the same page as us um
and they've even incorrectly you know
marked videos so sometimes like i said i
do think there's favoritism um or you
know maybe somebody do has a vendetta
against you it seems like there might be
that and also is there is a it seems
like to me like someone like james
charles
who's a fan or someone he has a fan
there who's just watching my account
like a hawk that could just [ __ ] bop
me whenever i post a video that's like
you know
i i don't doubt it i mean i genuinely
don't doubt it but that would be
somebody even higher up that would that
could possibly do that who's you know
actually looking at your account because
like hypothetically i thought let's just
hypothetically say trisha was like went
and reported your video it wouldn't even
make sense because wouldn't she just you
know go report that entire account
because that account just puts her on
blast
so
um i don't think it's necessarily
anybody specific um because if it's
going down within 10 minutes i highly
doubt it's just regular users reporting
you um i honestly do feel like there's
somebody higher up that might be
honestly looking at your account and
kind of keeping tabs on you
yeah well
you know
we have basically i just want to thank
you
no this is this is you basically you are
the edward snowden of tick tock exposed
yeah you are and i i wish i had like the
power to like actually restore the video
and stuff but i'm hoping i was able to
give you guys some clarity on how the
moderation process works um i'm a big
fan i've been watching h3 for years and
i'm a member and thank you wow we love
we got a man inside
yeah i love you guys the crew what you
guys do you guys make honestly
everything so much entertaining and you
guys hear that all the time so i really
appreciate you guys thank you so much is
there anything else we should know any
juicy inside scoops
uh nothing nothing too juicy um i mean
we see stuff definitely like you know
okay so you remember when the whole
david thing came up with the excavator
yep yeah so i remember that video was
nobody was able to find it for a hot
minute and it came up on my feed at work
actually and i was able to screencap the
video um and uh i saw the whole thing
happening i couldn't find it online but
it just happened to come across
my desk and i was like oh my god holy
[ __ ] i can't believe i've actually like
i've now seen the video before it
actually ever came out and ever jeff put
out that video and it was crazy
basically the people who owned the
excavator and rented it out to them they
were the ones recording it um when it
happened
dude
that's crazy and you scream and you
recorded it
well yeah
i'm not gonna lie
to my friends i was like dude
no way it was crazy yeah it was from a
fire distance they were they were on
land obviously but obviously just a few
yards away when they were watching it
happen you just watch them get bogged
hard did it have a lot of views by the
time it reached like your desk or was it
still small
um some do and some don't because the
video that i found was a re-upload so it
seemed that some people had were already
re-uploading it and
screen recording it so the one i got was
like a screen recorded uh video because
they had gotten it taken down they they
scrubbed that video clean off the
internet i'm curious what's the most
like frequent
rule breaking content you see
so it's weird because um when we're
moderating even if it's not we have like
a list so when it comes to my desk we
have the video it's almost like you know
your regular feed but next to it there's
a list of all of the policies and
basically you have to click each one of
the policies that it's breaking and it
filters out because different countries
don't allow
a certain content uh content to be
uploaded to uh their areas like alcohol
or
um torso minor and so it really just
filters so there's not like a specific
one that's always uh broken i mean you
see definitely a lot of underage users a
lot of minors i will say that's the
biggest thing there's always a lot of
little kids on there and you're just
constantly wondering like where are your
parents because they're doing some crazy
[ __ ] on there oh my goodness
is there a rule uh
prohibiting content that you think is
like the dumbest rule
um
nothing
nothing really that dumb like i really
do understand the reasoning uh behind
each policy and stuff um i just think
that like i said the the moderating
i don't know some moderators are not
paying attention or things go under the
table because it's just like i on my own
for you page i i come by stuff and i'm
like why is this on here or um i'm
surprised that it even made it to my
page that i'm seeing it because when i'm
i'm
i'm a tick tock user and when i'm on it
first of all i'm like in my head
constantly moderating even i can never
just enjoy the video
but um yeah i see stuff and i'm like how
did this even make it on there because
that's what i'm saying though some
people get under the radar every day i
saw dude
i saw a dude straight with his dick out
a fully direct dick and it had like
millions of views and we've been up for
weeks yeah
yeah the ai system is not full proof
which is what the moderators are there
for so there's two different types of
moderators one who
moderates content that is already
visible to the public that the ai system
is not detected and then there's a
moderators who get stuff that's um the
ai system did detect or it's been
reported which is typically what i
usually do so i see the stuff before
it's um visible or it gets to your
actual for you page
well thank you anonymous you're bringing
the truth to the people
keep it on my account okay and keep an
eye on james charles dude you you report
every single one of his right date for
endangering a minor
endangering a minor which it is all
right take care you're going to be okay
and i have a safe house in russia if you
need help contact
thanks guys all right love you bye
i mean pretty much confirmed like you
know i'm pretty sure your account has
like uh
for sure there's no question yeah
and also a james charles stan who's just
trying to [ __ ] with me
sister sniper by the way if we ready for
tick tock we confirmed her identity
before we brought her on so she's
definitely the real deal
i mean the process doesn't surprise me
you've got a lot of people out there
the way that tiktok works is just like
content content content content so the
moderation is hard but what i don't like
is when it happens to me
it makes sense
does that make sister sense it does make
sisters
uh let's look for something fun to talk
about facebook's rebranding
what a nightmare nightmare
[ __ ] you zak you dumb [ __ ] freak and i
made the zuck
we have some fun memes for that though
on the meat show so let's see facebook
is planning to change its name since
everybody hates uh facebook and thinks
they're destroying society so they're
like a little uh little rebrand should
uh band-aid that
you know
little rebranding brand trick we will
effectively transition from people
seeing us primarily being a social media
company to being a metaverse company
they said metaverse
you're not ready for the zucker verse
what does that even mean
it's more than just a social media
platform it's
vr we want your soul right they want to
create your reality they want to be your
reality can you just [ __ ] chills up
just take a vacation you own hawaii just
go [ __ ] be free
roam the planes and leave us all the
[ __ ] alone
right
right
the name is mark zuckerberg the year
2025 i have created the metaverse i am
uploading digital consciousness to our
systems we are enslaving all of humanity
we are running out of energy and we need
to harvest their bodies uh electric
currents to make batteries for our
robots we are putting we are putting
humans in sacks as they sleep into our
metaverse i am harvesting their energy
they are born into sacks the computers
are roaming the earth we have shut up
the sky so the sun cannot shine welcome
to the zuckerbergs also we are smoking
meats i am smoking meat at the same time
we need more electricity to smoke more
meats
well i'm making meats now smoking these
meats here welcome to the
here
rebranding facebook with honesty here's
a little glimpse to the zuckerverse
dude i hate that he's talking about
metaverse that makes me uncomfortable
the boomer brainwashed
that's pretty accurate i vote for that
i'll be back
[ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
digital civilization destroyer
let me get a close-up of his face there
yeah he loves it
get down
never seen him happier
yeah mask off
uh here he is with of course
digital human meat supply
meat chef
well that's nice at least they're
digital human meat they're not harming
real people that
kind of looks like ai too
totally we just need the red in his eyes
and that's it yeah
his skin is very slimy and uh
yeah the zuckerberg i hate this
this is the worst news i've had all year
the metaverse is a virtual reality space
in which users can interact with a
computer-generated environment and other
users yeah
welcome to the metaverse i am zuck i
live forever in the metaverse i am the
game master
you will bow to me
fools
the meat verse
oh yes
talk about being energetically aligned
zuck said the metaverse is going to be a
big focus and i think that this is just
going to be a big part of the next
chapter for the way the internet evolves
after the mobile internet and i think
it's going to be the next big chapter
for our company too ripley really
doubling down this area shut up zuck
freak
[Music]
the rebound would likely position the
blue facebook app as one one of many
products under a parent company okay who
cares
he's such a villain i hate him so much
he's such a freak
zeus
he's what
lucy
what does that
mean sorry i like how you never
understand on the present right
suck mixed with the p word
oh zeus how am i still not getting it
as long as you destroy it
i'll destroy it
i'll hit that [ __ ] so hard there'll
never be another zuckerverse again
i'm destroyed
um
he's such an evil [ __ ] though
maybe instead of like on january 6 we
can have people raid it virtually
instead of like acting doing it
you know
what is this facebook page segment
speaking of the zucky zucky zucky sucky
so cam showed me this tick tock page
that curates like really weird facebook
groups
it's pretty interesting here is uh it's
called mess mess up men with extremely
small penises
let's be honest that you kind of do need
a support group for that that's good the
small dong rally right dan
oh that's happening like this weekend
isn't it are you attending
solidarity in solidarity
you have something you want to tell us
[Laughter]
it's not all friends on facebook yes so
here we go this is the mesp or men with
extremely small penises facebook group
if there's one episode you should take
seriously it's this one this is a
serious medical condition that you
should not make fun of because it really
sucks to have i agree or yeah so i've
read all the way back in 2008 david
describes an all-too-common experience
for men who have the double misfortune
of having an esp and and it almost
sounds like they have psychic abilities
esp right
so maybe it comes in hand you get a tiny
penis but you also can read thoughts
that's a trade-off yeah honestly i i
take a normal penis over psychic over
psychic abilities yeah i take that
pretty much over anything and not even
like a hog just like a normal size
because keemstar [ __ ]
dude that's got to [ __ ] you up bad
having like a micropene
and you know the micro penises i've seen
them they're like they're like this bro
it's like real bad
it's not a good situation and i mean
that with peace and love
well there i mean
it sucks but i'm sure they get
past that
oh my god i would have a little kid i
wouldn't and i'm not like super like you
can find someone who doesn't care
to be with you
i really do
it's not even like dude but even if you
do it's just there's male there's just
so much like insecurity and just there's
just so much bad feelings tied in with
that like just like having to be with
someone for the first time and take your
pants off like do you know how stressful
that would be like oh my god you get
that crotch rod i feel like you can't
just surprise without you gotta talk
about it but yeah you you have to
disclose it
yeah
if anyone's listening i would not
surprise my heart goes out for real like
i'm i'm not i'm not kidding and i'm not
like penis obsessed like
i don't care you know about like if it's
i don't need an eight inch hog or
anything like that i'm just saying like
you know you can have a five incher and
that's like fine and normal and happy
but like this is this is
this dude i'm [ __ ] myself that's
hard
you just gave zach a lot of gold in the
last like 15 seconds
it's all good dude pan for it baby
that's why we're here
when do you think you gotta disclose
that
yeah
second date second date
or two early if you're planning on
having sex i feel like yeah right so
you're about to take your pants off
i've already taken my pants off
before yeah earlier than that look to
some women let's be honest there it's
important
well i also just think that that would
make the person with the micro penis
more comfortable right they'd be like i
want to tell you about this thing
there's a situation yeah yeah just like
btw
well well so you guys tell us then once
you guys expose the their tiny p as
penis truth
i think pretty early on in my opinion i
would say like the date that you are
assuming you'll have sex
on youtube like maybe if you go to okay
maybe if you go to dinner before be like
hi i want to talk to you about something
well oh man that's just see that that's
just so sucks that you have to do that i
yeah my life isn't fair my wife went out
on our wedding night i was like too late
you already said
i was like no take backs
wow you guys waited until marriage huh
yeah
that's weird because you slept with the
other girl in your town
[Laughter]
oh um
i don't like your perspective being so
negative for the people out there that
have that condition they're listening to
being like thank you ethan
it's hard out there i'm trying to tell
them i'm trying to tell them like i
understand your pain my friends ethan
have you ever seen howard stone's micro
penis contest yes
it's sad it is sad
but like some of their penises go in
they're so small yeah but seriously i
feel like there's
got to be
women out there or guys depending but
that would not care about it sure yeah
everything
just saying just saying
it's not even about you though it's
about the man and whatever who care my
penis is fine people say i did my penis
is small but not micro by the way watch
love on the spectrum
not not related but what's that got to
do with microphones
not related but just seeing them with
their disability trying to find love too
it's kind of like reminding me of that
because so what having autism is like
having a micro penis no actually i mean
they micro penis is a lot easier because
you think so yeah yeah yeah great sound
bite thank you thank you
it's really sad but it's also really
cute
and like it's just everything it does
it's a roller coaster it actually does a
lot to humanize people with uh autism
too because they i mean it's just
they're really special beautiful people
kind of like
you kind of get to know their side of
what it's like
and
they're actually really cool people yeah
they're all each one has like their own
special interest
i want to hang out with michael really
bad
which one's funny michael
so this show's pretty popular yeah but
there's a couple
that did find love
right
uh if you watched the last super yeah
yeah yeah yeah but the couple that i was
rooting for they broke up yeah i know i
think i know well there was one couple
in there that was like married they were
both autistic and they were made
and they were like they're on the second
season too yeah god bless them love them
so anyway back to small penises uh
there's [ __ ] all over the floor well
here let me read his post a lot of you
may not know this but i'm an audi
sometimes girls often confuse my longer
belly button with my shorter penis
especially the ones i have sex with
because they are heavily intoxicated as
embarrassing as this is i kind of find
it arousing when it grows all up in my
umbilicus i guess it's a fetish i'd like
to share with the girl don't knock it to
you wait what's the term umbilicus his
umbilical cord where his belly button is
that's a pretty deep cut and he has a
comment fascinated
leon is i can't tell if this is a troll
or not at this point
oh he's saying my penis is so small he
has an audi belly button
that actually protrudes more okay and so
sometimes the girl's confused because he
only sleeps with super intoxicated girls
probably because he's so insecure they
confuse the belly button for the phallus
and it turns him on
so
does that sound like a guy who's coping
with his uh condition to you either
sounds like a fetish
girls often confuse my longer belly
button with my shorter penis especially
oh he's reading the post already did
that
already read it
oh he's actually showing people like
don't do that
or maybe it's just beauty lobby it's not
the 500 douchebags okay we've talked
about this enough shout out to my small
pianist
legends out there
shout out to the small penis
[ __ ]
rock stars
this one's about apple juice how weird
can that be
[Music]
okay for the nose of people who think
i'm just joking
to clean your sinuses oh no this isn't
about apple juice is it
olivia found this one
yes it is actually
oh no
[Music]
oh in the nose
oh
man people take [ __ ] too far bro why
people just always have to take [ __ ] way
too far that's so high
he edited it like that he did oh
my god
he's got kendrick lamar in the
background too
he edited it like this
i mean he pulls the stuff straight from
the facebook page
no way bro i really hope i guess i gotta
try it before i knock it if it feels
that good okay
i want that yeah
it's like it's never enough with these
people it's like i gotta ferment my piss
i gotta drink my piss and then he's like
no no no i gotta snort my piss i'm
pretty sure that is apple juice it's
apple juice oh it is there's a there's
another group that we have videos from
yeah we we ended up skipping the
fermentation no it's just stop it says
urine therapy at the top oh it does yeah
he's sniffing urine oh god no he's
sniffing urine oh my god no
well i have two more i thought it was
apple juice i did there are two more way
too normal
nobody's wants to sniff apple juice
yeah i've been on the internet too long
to know
okay this [ __ ] tick tock it keeps
going to weird i just want to watch the
dude snort urine please
play it yeah so it's like i was saying
it's like it's never enough people gotta
take [ __ ] way too [ __ ] far all the
time you know
i gotta give myself a urine enema
i got a shower in it i gotta drink it
it's like bro
maybe i'm gonna pee in my trash can done
there's a quartering sound bite for
everything now
let's just do come on there's not you
don't need to be like the ultimate piss
god
just drink it man i don't know
it's like a normal person yeah it's like
why you gotta be so extra
here's another piss god our friends on
facebook as long as the united states
continues its shameless resistance
against socialized healthcare people
will continue to seek out alternative
medicine like their own [ __ ] piss oh
that's actually a really interesting
take
he might actually be on to something
like if people had access to actual
medicine that didn't cost them a fortune
they might not be drinking their piss
that's fine so it's only a matter of
time before i made a return to the urine
therapy facebook group and this time i
haven't covered the most batshit crazy
health fad since butthole tanning
soaking your eyeballs and piss in this
pose
it's just not necessary
it's too much just you go you take it
too far
why did i take it so far i soak your
eyeball on anything just drink it like a
[ __ ] civilized person
i wonder if the people who drink it just
feel like those guys are crazy holy [ __ ]
you've seen that girl so
that that girl is nuts
steve compliments on her sparkling eyes
as a result of her dripping pressure let
me guess her visions are decreased
twice daily i'm guessing like how
regular people use eye drops which means
that this is really only on her eyes for
a few minutes i mean her eyes do look
good if only there was a way to keep her
eyes shaken all day
oh
they got to show the other piss people
that they're the piss king and they take
[ __ ] all the way no half sins
one's eyes is no longer a matter of
minutes but of hours simply take a pair
of swim goggles fill them with piss drop
them off and go about your day it's that
simple
yellow dragon his name is no way
pissed
yellow dragon
doing black i am not liable
congratulations pissed yellow dragon you
are the friend of the day our friends on
facebook that's for real that is
that's a good find olivia
thank you
you were in the trenches this time
here's another one
i love the investigative journalism
going on our friends on facebook is a
great account
yeah that's an awesome recommendation
our friends on facebook i found the
facebook group urine therapy
representatives and advocates because
well i'll let you in on a little secret
big pharmacist camp just drink your own
piss one post asked the
2366 golden guzzlers in the group to
share what made them start golden
guzzling in the first place
which is a really good question because
i'm having trouble coming up with a
scenario where i'd say
gee you know i i should piss in a cup
and drink it so curiously i went to the
comments section and came across
christopher here who straight up says
i don't know i just like the taste of it
christopher then posted on the questions
of his own what will happen if you put
sperm stop it bro nobody wants to know
that
christopher already taking it too far
there's that can't be part of the
therapy you got to pick one bodily fluid
and stick with it
if you want to watch a streamer then you
might be honest with something nothing
oh sorry uh
his profile to try to understand what he
looks like
honestly he kind of looks like a piss
drinking
he looks like robin williams from the uh
that one movie where he was like working
at a photoshop as a psycho and that is
goku i mean you can't prove the super
saiyan just practice urine therapy but
we can't prove that they don't practice
it either congratulations christopher
you are the friend of
[ __ ]
you know i'm just upset i can't get in
this facebook group man they still
haven't accepted me wait you applied
yeah when did you apply a while ago
probably about two weeks ago three weeks
ago
i guess they're busy they got a lot
they got a lot of applications would
they decline you or probably now yeah
i wonder if they make you do like a
proof
you have to send in a video of you
chugging it raw well they make you sign
their version of a non-disclosure
agreement yeah i'm sure they're coming
after you
yeah sure
the piss drinkers united is uh coming
hard but i mean this is amazing content
so i'm just bummed
here's another one from our friends on
facebook twitter account this one is
about um filipino women and u.s men our
friends on facebook filipino women for
usa amen is a facebook group in which
foreign broads throw their best game at
overweight middle-aged american men who
haven't busted a nut since their divorce
yeah i'm going to generalize that's the
reality i struck golden literally the
first post i encountered janet says
single and living in jihadi kuwait
looking for a wealthy man to support me
and my four kids usually i'll use your
money please live in kuwait no
no way
what it's american or british only white
only please hvs2 controlled with
medication
she has [ __ ] hiv
no no no what's hvs it's herpes but he
says it oh i thought that was oh okay
still crazy well at least she's up front
about it remember casual racism is okay
in her comments
i went to the comments section and found
a potential suitor he asked what's hvs2
good thing you asked butch it's herpes
janet tries to make it advanced but it's
too late as butch now knowing she has
herpe mouth comes in with an oh [ __ ] you
know how this sounds good
except for herpes actually i'll come
back with you oh
wow this guy is in the trenches man
congratulations janet you are the friend
of the day i love this guy's videos what
the [ __ ] this guy is awesome
teachers with long fingernails man
specifically teachers that's what it
says yeah teachers with long fingernails
our friends on facebook yet again
uh that looks graphic what is that photo
of
well don't show it yeti is it blurred
i just want to make sure now our friends
on facebook i will tell you now that
this is truly taxing on the soul to make
for some reason there exists a facebook
group called teachers with long
fingernails and toenails why teachers
you might ask their bio reads you're
back in high school on your page don't
know secretary or teacher don't show
that is sporting something out of the
ordinary five on the toes and five on
the fingers that are razor sharp and
long claws would give you a fantasy of
your choice you know just something that
we've all thought about three things the
first post that i go ahead
yeah
oh my god
dude why are these they're like thin it
makes me impressive
rival the three-toed sloth yeah i went
to the comments and found an absolute
simp show
john says anna please post more of your
nails i am your fan forever i love you
can i interrupt real quick profile
honestly uh ian can you take it off it
it's gonna loop just so you know so
it's gonna show that part in the
beginning so
okay thank you i'll keep buying it
pretty unremarkable makes you wonder how
many seemingly normal people you know
have a thing for long toenails
congratulations john you are the friend
friend of the day
uh metal
male pedal pushing
oh this wait i saw this guy separately
didn't we
this is sort of a segway to the next
section okay good oh yeah so oh we have
a whole new
uh there's no such thing as a
coincidence
holy [ __ ] yeah so there's a meme hole we
stumbled upon
actually this found this started
because
people were getting this as an ad on
[ __ ] youtube i'll get into that let's
watch this first and then i'll explain
[Music]
it's just pushing the pedals baby this
may be copyright
it's a it's a foot fetish thing males
pedal uh pedal pumping
and that was specific
the song was gas pedal is she not
talking
some boots steps on the gas i'm talking
really puts the pedal to the metal
[Music]
okay well you guys get the idea that's
the thing so
yeah somebody it started
um
yeah so this dude posted this and i saw
it because comment etiquette
retweeted it and this is a [ __ ] ad
that youtube is currently serving to
people can't rewind because this is on
uh my console but uh this gentleman
uh is rambling through
uh about how he wants to
recruit people to barefoot drive
and he just showed a shot of his feet
while driving a vehicle
it's awesome make videos have a good
time i will pay you to make a bunch of
videos
[Laughter]
and i'll provide
all right so luckily for you guys
um i found the whole video and his
channel
hotmail.com okay i've heard that in so
long
so we found his channel
he is the uh we should probably give a
warning
why well
like extreme islamophobia in this video
there is yeah
i don't remember i'm prepared hit me
wait what did he do
he don't like the muslims you don't like
the most [ __ ]
okay well trigger warning as the onboard
muslim i say proceed okay well fair
barefoot brothers drive is the name of
his channel
here's the ad it only has 130 views man
this is a deep cut not even a single
like or dislike
this is raw this is like virgin oh i
guess maybe it's not in this video is it
it's the other one that we have in there
yeah i don't remember anything like it's
in his warning video okay so i haven't
seen that one
so this one says this one's safe as long
as you're not triggered by bare feet
guys it's me back sea man
with our beautiful feet at the pedals
all of us i'm introducing my my site
came out i fixed it up it looks really
lovely great for brothersdrive.com go to
my youtube channel barefoot brothers
drive
and also as for continuation i need
drivers to drive for me i'll pay them
good money they'll make money and i'll
make money you can use your own car
which would be great or you can also fly
to new york and you can use my car if
you need it too that's no problem you
can arrange that um the pay will be
discussed but you make 15 short 15
minute videos maybe a few teachers as
well we could put you on
my youtube channel tell me more drivers
will
get your feet out there and
make some money and have some fun doing
something we love it's a fun happy easy
feel good business a very easy job for
any guy out there this is like one dude
this is like one pebble
throw away from being human sex
trafficked
like this guy
it's fun easy fun wholesome thing to do
then you wake up like squid games in the
back of a van
on your way to some [ __ ] someone's
basement in russia just feel good feel
comfortable feel wonderful with those
beautiful feet at the pedals and let's
make a difference let's show our love
with our feet and let's be proud all
right and let's bring it up to our
brothers with our feet all the best
instead of information
he's driving it's information at
barefoot.com
which is info
barefootbrosedrive.com or you can go on
my s foot continuation youtube channel
or you can contact me if you're barefoot
bro you got dude something terrible
happened to him when he was a kid that's
for sure
i like that he has those leds in the
footwell so at night you could probably
still see the feet oh
good thinking
actually i would love to see the
the night uh version of that let me look
probably nice
so this one is a warning video so this
one has uh some oh it was age restricted
oh they didn't take it down though
okay
i guess that's probably sure you want to
watch this well not if it's age
restricted because that'll hit us too
right yeah no let's not watch that so it
wasn't before it must have just
they got it yeah they got it
he just wants you to drive and you video
yeah easy job you just you drive
barefoot
for 15 minutes he films you easy gig
somehow he's making money from that
yeah you can buy the videos on his
website apparently i'm not sure he's
making money to be totally honest with
you
he might be thank you
thank you
i got a saudi delivery
[Music]
shredder is attacking lena
i need to pee again
go ahead all right you guys know when
you're pregnant you pee a lot because
the bladder gets squeezed i feel like
especially lately
there's like
he became a lot bigger or something and
it's like sitting right on top of oh the
bladder yeah bomber
that's brutal
so um i don't know would you do that
zach because you seem kind of interested
it's intriguing i mean i like to drive
and i mean you like to let your feet
breathe yeah sometimes you know
i i mean it's intriguing so he says he
says talk to me we'll negotiate a price
what do you think his price range is 10
bucks
it's probably something shitty i'm
thinking like a hundred 200 bucks
probably if it's bad then [ __ ] yeah i'll
do it
sure i'll pay 200 enough to do it about
that i think we've all gotten like cameo
requests to show our feet yeah yeah
that's a really popular fetish it is
nobody ever asked me for my feed though
what are you the king what are you
talking about
i guess mine is so easily available
nobody needs to pay me for it
yeah but definitely an intriguing gig
well you know where to contact him
um is there any other ones we can watch
because i feel oh he we found the
nighttime one yeah
oh wait
you are totally you called that bro
you've gotten the mind of madness on
that one
beautiful hot feet i've installed those
lights before that's the only reason i
recognize no way bro you totally
predicted that
here's his dream car the uh
flintstones foot powered car
yeah he probably dreams of that
yeah
he'd be beating off if he was in that
car
just two bros yabba-dabba-doing
yeah look you know you got to see this
av totally called this guy
putting socks in he got a night vision
on his feet
would you do this
oh my god uh no
i declined the cameo that requested me
for it
like at all not for money i don't know
that's weird
i mean if i'm like wearing sandals and
i'm already a thousand bucks thousand
bucks hell yeah yeah exactly like if
someone is not offering enough yeah
up there
business okay got it yeah business price
for feet you have a business price on
cameo
yeah i haven't changed mine since i
started your business price
i'm honestly not sure i the guys know i
know how much there is are what is this
ten times
mine's uh
mine's 300. did anyone buy any business
options from you guys i have one i've
had one yeah really yeah what was the
request
uh he wanted me to write him a full yo
what the [ __ ] you guys got lower first
when did this happen
when did you guys start adding
what the oh my gosh
he um he wanted me to write him a full
like production theme song and uh oh so
okay oh that's cool that's cool yeah
they got you weren't here but they were
arguing
about who's done the most cameos because
ian was getting genuinely upset
at zach because he wrote he's the king
of camden i did not write that that was
that no no no no no no no no worse it
was the best cameos in town the best
cameos
and ian took slide at that right so i i
changed it and i said the best musical
cameos in town is that okay for you ian
that was fine i mean i just started
seeing this best cameo in town promotion
right and last time i checked ab and i
live
uh in the same town so you know i'm out
of the i'm out of the race
the truth is though the fact that you
guys even can pretend to hold a candle
to white club gabe
we bounce out
in all seriousness there's no
competition there
can't believe you guys added lower
thirds for your cameos um
so are you guys still going at it strong
yeah they've done like 200.
ian what are you you're at 199 i don't
need to disclose let's just say this too
late now
ian and i are pretty neck and neck
they're at 200 a piece right now i'm at
100. so ian did you find a format that
doesn't take you as long
kind of i still waste some time but
mobile premiere is fantastic numbers
don't lie
we uh we've done our first uh
uh engagement or um wedding proposal
oh together well no no i've i've had a
problem yeah i proposed to zach
maybe next time
ian's had one i've had about two i think
abe had one too
you did i think i did
well it was really impactful
clearly
go through themselves what a special key
moment for them i was gonna put up uh
for the best cameos in the galaxy hit me
up on instagram but they were going at
it already so i was like let them wait
you wanna you're trying to take the the
traffic off cameo straight to instagram
and charge them directly no no i'm just
saying because that's where we advertise
actually only zach advertises me ian
don't really advertise zach does like
except when you when you put lower
thirds without telling me i have the
lower thirds
yeah
that was hilarious
um
let's see so basically let's move it on
to uh steve harvey
steve harvey ely you're the fashionista
so you can rate these fits for me
steve harvey's been out of control
with this fits
he's dressed like a pimp yeah
he just needs a cane and
i think it's the styling issue because
like i don't i don't mind the purple
suit but then like
the way it fits with that shoe
and the jacket with no hands inside i'm
sorry but i'll never get down with the
jacket with no hands inside it's like
what do you even goth them bro just use
the sleeves
or just embrace the cape at that point
just wear a cape yeah
it's basically a cape
and that's fine but just like no half
cents i mean you're going to wear a cape
wear a cage that's interesting maybe
just wear a cape bro bring capes back i
mean what's the deal well no the words
of uh george costanza never trust a man
in a cape exactly yeah i wish he'd done
full monochrome like lavender i feel
like that would have been much cooler
right to me i think uh the feet of the
pants is a little too tight for his age
listen us up there harvey just
proportionately i don't like that and i
don't love the shoes the fit's actually
pretty good though i think it's that
goes pretty hard the other fits go off
the rails here
let's see
and here let's let's check this fit out
he's got the glossy i mean this one's
not bad either it's a little glossy
though
looks like a [ __ ]
tuba lipstick
even the shirt is glossy underneath
but wait this isn't the crazy ass fits
he's got way worse fits than these
these are normal
i didn't i mean
i didn't really perceive him as having
crazy fits i mean
not crazy he's just going for it yeah
that's that was my impression well
you'll know there are some that are bad
which i'll get to um
but
these are not them
uh here we have an album
of how old is he
here you you'll see like you can see the
fit under the meme people started
memeing his fits he's 64.
okay
is that okay for you either
too old gotta tone it down just i don't
know i just feel like it could be a lit
a little more appropriate to his age but
um yeah so here's a fit and leather
pants blue jacket straight poking
pokemon trainer ah that's not hot
again i just feel like his pants are too
tight they are so tight he's so tight
and you can see everything any jeans my
dude oh you can't right
now yes
kind of
i mean there's something there but you
can't but yeah i'm not confident like
dude you're 64 years old let's tuck that
thing away bro
uh here he is uh my hero academia
um
like that's a crazy fit to me the
leprechaun fit i don't know
the lucky charms fit what do you think
about it i don't hate it you don't hate
it i also don't hate it yeah at least i
can't see this this one is better
but i said the monochrome is so much
cooler and the pants are not as tired
dude this house is nice look at him he's
got like this dude lives like
i get the feeling that steve harvey
really
he is the type of dude live in a castle
you know what i mean look at that door
like jesus
come on down here i actually don't know
what anime this is from but it's pretty
fire fit i like the hardware
oh this is yugo yeah i never watched
that one
oh another uh mf doom
that one's pretty cool that one is
looking pretty good
this one is uh
trunks trunks yeah oh that jacket is
exactly like trunks wait which which
shows that from dbz dragon ball
never watch dragon ball
for the being of i'm like a mega weave i
mean i watch all animes
but i didn't watch that old [ __ ] when i
was a kid
spiderman doctor octopus
uh
uh captain america
i don't know what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] is just hitting the car now
like what do you think about this fiddy
though that's pretty wild no
i need a better picture
it's just so funny this is a wildfire
wait what
what's going on here
i don't know man
huh
yeah that one this is a show from uh
what was this one called i watched it
it's a new one
oh yeah
jiu-jitsu jujutsu it's good it's a good
show
and then is that me
what's this oh is this a real bad oh
here's the yellow fit oh that's kind of
fire
dude
he's having fun i'm too fat to dress
nice so he's taking care of himself at
least
you know
yeah but did you guys see how hot he
looked
yeah he looked he did look good
is that like
was he always dressing like this or is
it just kind of like a new era
i think he was always well dressed but
he's just really i think somebody told
him hey you should show
he stepped off his fits a little bit
dude
check yeah he's he's flexing on us all
this peasant
the green one i think is the best one
really i'm gonna start dressing all in
green for her
his suits are always pretty fly on
family feud ricky always very dapper i'm
about to come dressed up all in green
no hate
so
the nilk boys we made a content chord on
them
and
this is a new prank
they just put out a couple days ago
it's really [ __ ] up um you know what
ice is right
ice
i don't know what it stands for but i
know they just they basically are
immigration and customs enforcement yeah
they're like a special task force that
just [ __ ] with immigrants and deports
them yeah like no no shoddies or
anything i mean they have a bad
reputation too for just being violent
thug freaks
yeah
and they have their own jurisdiction
kind of uh
yeah they were created as part of
homeland security after 9 11.
and uh
they sucked but it seems like they
mostly like it's funny because they
mostly just are targeting like
you know mexican and south american
immigrants
that's correct yeah
so thanks to 911 we are now have a
special police force to [ __ ] with
uh mexican and south american immigrants
make that make sense to me i don't know
so nell thought it'd be funny to pull up
to like a bunch of dudes looking for
work in an ice van so i got some extra
modelos if you guys want something
they're just pretty warm this is a
little warm yeah then we can buy a ice
bath oh [ __ ] ice
yeah oh [ __ ] ice is coming why is this
coming here
oh
god
wow
full send
you moments of cold beers
let me run i
ice no i did you like your beer is warm
oh
no no no why you guys do that do what
you look like [ __ ] immigration i
didn't want you guys to drink warm beers
i got some uh yeah so again they're
always with milk it's always [ __ ]
with people
it's always
[ __ ] with people
when was this made recently just a few
days ago no yeah and actually really
yeah yeah yeah it's brand new right i
mean i was just posting it was posted to
their
uh twitter account october 18th that was
like right after we made our content
card
like 10 years ago vibe i don't know why
well what's especially bad about it is
that their friends
and like are huge trump simps so it's
not even like a joke like these guys
probably do hate immigrants right which
makes it even worse it's a vibe right
now and ironic since they are
from canada they import them they are
immigrants right yeah
we're good immigrants they're
[ __ ] up and we can [ __ ] with these
guys
and you know it's just not that funny
because ice are actually like terrorists
and these people have anomalies here you
know if they get deported they like
[ __ ] lose everything you know it's
just it's real [ __ ] i don't think
anyone who doesn't hate immigrants would
do something like this right
yeah because they clearly see them as
like their play thing
yeah i was super disturbed by this
actually
i just don't know
that's awful i just don't know
but uh people love it i mean this is
like total red pill click bait
i'm mexican and i found this funny
totally
100
exactly
it's just
uh that's yeah i think they're just
pandering to to mega crowd with this one
that's just like probably the worst
piece of content
that i've seen
in the last year
okay so everyone's [ __ ] on him
that's good at least in the quote tweets
i think it was like a teaser for new
videos what i'm saying oh and that's
gonna backfire i'm not seeing it on
their youtube channel because they got
so much [ __ ] but they they post it on
twitter and instagram i mean they never
took it down from twitter they should
totally delete it
they've gotten first of all they've
gotten so much hate so they should know
because people are telling them because
they clearly didn't because when they
did it
but because they're being told this is
so wrong by literally everybody they
should delete it sounding like a real
[ __ ] half center right now i hope
they poked it i'm so sorry i actually
hope they post it because they already
did it to these people i guess yeah and
i hope that they are dumb enough i hope
they get the full review
yeah if you did it you did it
post it and deal with it
you know if you're such an epic
pranksters they're being half centers i
know i mean there's plenty of people who
are going to be like yeah but they'll
also they're probably like white
nationalists like uh i didn't know
people still make this kind of content
you know like the videos that we used to
react to like in our beginning of our
channel
yeah that's crazy yeah you said earlier
earlier you said this is like humor from
like 10 years ago almost exactly 10
years ago that
dude ari shafir shafir whatever
um oh who's always on joe rogan yeah who
unfortunately i kind of look like um
anyways he he made almost this exact
video like 10 years ago that was like
mega viral all over the internet n word
or was it well he did that too
he was part of the same series of uh
wonderfully uh hilarious we could make
like a classic h3 video to this
he would go to like home depot and pick
up a bunch of day laborers and then be
like i'm taking you to border control ha
ha ha and then they freak out and like
jump out of the truck it's even more
[ __ ] up to like kidnap them
yeah i mean i guess it is even a little
bit worse yeah
in the car you know it's a similar
premise and um yeah it's uh very 2009
humor same guy who was saying that he
was happy kobe bryant died on the day he
died
he already said that yeah what did he
say
he's epic edge lord lol xd was he just
saying that he said he's glad kobe he
just
says yeah
yeah so he's always on joe rogan by the
way joe rogan loves him why would
anybody say that he i don't know
whenever i saw him on joe rogan i was
always shocked because i was like isn't
this the guy who did like the n-word
pranks and all these horrible like he
was fully canceled i thought like a
total [ __ ] bag
but uh what the [ __ ] do i know joe loves
him so he's [ __ ] in
what's his name
are you sorry ari
are you sure
yeah he's jewish
where he's from though he's one of the
good ones ela
he's one of the he's one of the
anti-woke jews
yeah this guy he i just remember him you
don't look like him then yeah you don't
look like him okay wait he does that
series on youtube with the he brings in
comedians
i mean yeah he's very famous damn i had
no idea oh [ __ ]
comedy clubs drop ari shafir after
comments on trouble what was his
comments let's look i i sent it in the
discord on the dave kobe's death on the
day of kobe bryant's death
comic ari shafir i think comics should
be in quote marks kobe bryant died 23
years too late today he got away with
our word because of all the hollywood
liberals who attack comedy enjoy rooting
for the lakers more than they dislike
our word
big ups to the hero who forgot to gas up
his chapter
i hate the lakers what a great day
there was a video that happened with it
as well well hold on what is it this
artwork oh my god he was he was actually
kobe was uh
yeah
there was a big thing with him
i thought he was accused of infidelity i
didn't know he was accused of war
so what was the situation with that then
maybe maybe he's onto something if
that's the gate no i
well he didn't
kobe didn't die alone that day but and
he tries to argue that he didn't know
that but
say what
kobe was one of many people who died in
that crash including his like
regardless of your feelings on kobe
bryant uh
because he says his younger daughter is
pretty disgusting
right big ups to the hero who forgot to
gass up that chopper
what a great day yeah his daughter died
and no matter what ever happened
and and how many in total like there was
like five or seven more i think yeah i
forget the total but yeah dude what a
[ __ ] but
the rest were kids too it was a bunch of
kids that died right
nine people there
nine people yeah
parents that must have been even his own
fans must have been like nah dude he got
in a lot of trouble for that one no it's
just i mean you want to talk about
allegations let's talk about it but this
is just disgusting
again i don't even know if he means it
he like his thing is being as offensive
as possible yeah that sounds like that's
how he defends it he's saying there's
nothing funny about it yeah he's saying
he's calling out hypocrisy of people
[ __ ] i don't know
[Laughter]
delete me from this conversation
oh yeah he famously uh um dosed uh bert
kreischer with ecstasy without his
knowledge that's [ __ ] up i remember
them talking about that on joe and he
was laughing about very dose
he put i think it was acid no no it was
ecstasy he put some drugs in his drink
without bert's consent
he's a psycho he's a [ __ ] freak show
dude i don't know why
this guy is beyond [ __ ]
yeah the stuff he used to do back in the
day was even worse than any of this
stuff man
chad wants us to talk about alec baldwin
oh sure yeah i mean
here i've got the details in the
document here
gosh if there's been any updates since
we started streaming
situation i haven't even checked the
news today well at first i saw there was
an accident and then we learned that it
was alec baldwin who shot the gun
yeah so alec baldwin they were shooting
a scene for a western movie
and he had um
a prop gun that somehow
had
live ammunition i mean what how does
this happen so i think there's a lot of
confusion going around i know there's a
lot of confusion because i've seen on
social media people being like what the
[ __ ] it's not a prop
if it's a real gun um anything that is
used in a shot is a prop so being a prop
gun does not mean that it is not a
functioning firearm by any means
but why would they use a real one yeah
if it's because you know it if it's
being used for a scene it can be a prop
but it is a gun loaded with blanks
or something that's meant to obviously
not actually shoot
the whole situation makes no [ __ ]
sense though if you've ever
uh worked on a set where there are
actual firearms being used the
protocols are like insanely stringent
like
tons of meetings
um you know the the gun is generally
handled by an armorer licensed armor who
has to
loudly you know everybody stops what
they're doing and watches what they're
doing and he like
talks as he's doing okay i am now
loading it with the single blank shows
it to everybody hands it to the actor
everybody's very clear on what's going
on and so
uh how this could happen baffles me i
mean they obviously somebody massively
[ __ ] up for this thing there was a
there was a really famous mishap where
bruce lee's son brandon was killed in a
similar fashion years decades ago and
like that was shocking and the fact that
it could happen on such a huge budget
show
and i mean i honestly feel horrible for
alec like what a [ __ ] horrible thing
to be involved in killing somebody in
such a horrible way
it says let's see alec discharged a prop
firearm thursday on a movie set
killing the director of photography
ed woo dig the director so
yeah dan had a good theory that he was
probably shooting at the camera
and that the you know director of
photography was probably filming next to
the director
uh
oh interesting okay
somebody just messaged me
i'm hearing this live so let's take with
a grain of salt but apparently death
noodles reported this
that it was a live round and that part
of the issue is that uh the union crew
had gone on strike and they brought in
non-union people to continue filming and
uh
i guess they how the [ __ ] but like how
can you
how can you oh yeah somebody else just
said that in the chat yeah um like i
said i mean the last i had seen about
this was early this morning where there
really weren't that many details before
we went live so i guess there's been
some further information coming out
about the situation
yes so
the director photographer this is her
here
uh died
she was flown to a hospital she's 42
years old
and she [ __ ] died
uh baldwin is one of the film stars blah
blah blah
so here's an update
uh baldwin is speaking for the first
time since the tragic accident saying
there are no words to convey my shock
and sadness regarding the tragic
accident that took the life of um hi uh
halia hutchins
wife mother and deeply admired colleague
of ours on fully cooperating with the
police investigation to address how this
tragedy occurs
i am enti really at a time like this dan
at a time
like this
i'm in touch with her husband offering
my support to him and his family my
heart is broken for her husband their
son and all who knew and loved her
uh
so there was a live round in the gun
yeah i'm seeing this is one hour ago uh
rust camera crew walked off before
shooting uh the rus
camera crew walked up the set in protest
hours before fatal prop shooting um
so i guess they were
feeling like things were un
safe um wait wait they walked off what
the camera crew walked off because they
thought it was unsafe
that is what is being reporting as of uh
by the la times uh one hour ago
[ __ ]
you know what i
find really bizarre i i'm reading this
article on the new york times
and they're basically running through
the story and all the details
and then at the end
they're like um mr baldwin
you know he has a long career of movies
blah blah blah you played trump saturday
night live and then mr baldwin also has
a history of run-ins with the police
that is so [ __ ] so [ __ ] why would
you even say that in 2014 he was
arrested after he rode his bicycle the
wrong way on fifth avenue
what really like do we really need to
talk about you have times yes this is
the new time you guys need to get your
[ __ ] together why the [ __ ] would they
include that this guy acts this guy just
went through probably one of the worst
moments of his life easily and they're
being like oh he rode the wrong way in a
bike lane he has run-ins with the police
like somehow insinuating yeah
maybe he's shady yeah in 2019 mr baldwin
pleaded guilty to her harassment in
manhattan criminal court
[ __ ]
you that is
so upsetting
i was just reading it and i was like
wait what like why
that's disgusting why go there you know
they're like and there's a small chance
he may have murdered them in cold blood
because he was going
because he's driving the bicycle
oh my god that actually makes me want to
[ __ ] piss and puke and [ __ ] and piss
all over the floor just do it in goggles
and put it over your eyes
now you're thinking supervision yeah
wow um that's so upsetting that they
wrote that
yeah
comment on one of the articles
oh so this what is it just a random car
someone that commented it's just well
[ __ ] um you should show me mike uh
cernovich's tweet that's a real person
with the following not some random
[ __ ] in the comments
yeah so some people on the right wing
media ela
because you know alec baldwin is
prominent critic of trump and played him
on saturday live yeah they are spinning
this of course
as a w for republicans
here's one second what does this have to
do with politics well here they they
they make it make sense mike cernovic
hollywood uh
it was
he was one of the biggest [ __ ] freak
shows conservative freak shows on the
internet he made his own pill supplement
called gorilla mind
here he is anyway and it has 18 000
likes so this is a well
supported uh this guy is such a freak
bro
alec baldwin should be afforded
wait where's the other there was a
different tweet
i haven't read this one album should be
afforded all the due process he would
give others read some of his tweets then
get back to me so he wants him charged
for murder
um
okay you know the one i'm talking about
you sent there earlier dan
me about how it's karma
oh
michael delausen
yeah i don't think i i sent one from
mike cervich
but i'll send you something i thought
you did
the one who says it's like karma for
uh let's see
yeah this is a bunch of [ __ ]
um
here's one yeah cernovich here we go
this is it this is the tweet
watch this take ila
i do believe we summon energy with our
words and thoughts
and it's why i try to measure my own if
you're aware of the who this guy is he's
like the big that's just
so crazy to say but he says hollywood's
treatment of conservatives and disdain
for people that can't be overlooked as a
cause on a spiritual level of the alec
baldwin incident
hatred summons hatred
so there you go
wow
it's a
god it's a karma made alec baldwin shoot
and kill
if that if there was karma wouldn't it
be him being shot and not some other
person's life being lost
that's true
why does she have to die
yeah it's psycho [ __ ] man it's just it's
it's [ __ ] crazy
that's super sad though and i'm so sad i
can't imagine whoever put that ball in
that gun needs obviously for everyone
like who do you blame for that dan
somebody got to be held responsible for
that right
generally the first ad the first
assistant director on a film set is all
they
have the ultimate responsibility of
safety on set and can be criminally
liable also the producers
um
and then in the specific instances of a
firearm again they're
the protocol is to have a licensed armor
who's in charge of the weapons on set
and so i imagine they may share some
liabilities what the [ __ ] do you put a
real bullet exactly and a gun instead of
a set like i just why would it even be
near by anything yeah you know and i've
seen a lot of people
saying it's like um in this day and age
it's pretty unnecessary to even use
blanks it's very easy to simulate
gunfire with visual effects right right
it's like one of the easiest things you
can do i guess it looks more realistic
if it kicks back a little bit well you
can you can fake that you can just have
a mechanical gun that
that it yeah absolutely that's what i'm
saying i'm surprised they're even using
real guns at all
you can make a fake gun that's real as
[ __ ] yeah
indeed
well i think this might be the end of
using blanks in movies by the way people
are saying that the fact that they
define it as live round doesn't mean
necessarily a real bullet
yeah and people keep saying blanks kill
two yes that's true um a blank
i mean people are saying it was a blank
i don't think that we know that
what i've been looking at all the
articles right whatever it was i don't
know where you're hearing that the fact
that it's capable of killing anybody and
they bring that on to the set
but how it clearly if it was just like
one freak instant of a blank killing
someone he shot her and the director
like something doesn't make sense there
it was a freak occurrence how did he
manage to shoot two people yeah i mean
i'm seeing it reported
all over the place that it was not a
blank it was a live round so before he
gets to see i know but that means two
bullets had a freak occurrence
yeah somehow yeah
live round dancing that's what's being
reported
i'm not sure
why the chat is disagreeing with that
i'm looking at multiple articles where
that's being said
yeah it's so [ __ ] up i feel bad for
him man i really do and everybody
it's horrible
horrible horrible stuff
turns out we have a pretty good uh work
environment here
guns and bug assaults
so
yeah i'm watching live cnn coverage they
don't know yet um
that's gonna [ __ ] him up for life man
and not to i mean obviously the the
the poor uh woman who died in her family
yeah
it's horrible i'm very curious more
about to hear that people walked out
because it was unsafe like what did they
see
that was so unsafe that they walked out
and then everyone else resumed
that to me strikes me as very weird as
well
i mean here in this new york post
article it says a single live round was
accidentally fired on set by the
principal actor wow
i don't know
well it's being investigated so we'll
probably get
more details
oh speaker speaking of weird mysteries
too uh brian laundry
right
found we found we did it guys we found
his body
and uh
that [ __ ] is dead
die
yeah well if people keep saying live
round doesn't mean bullet okay what does
it mean then
i guess in there
it could just mean anything
what does it mean
if you can say it doesn't mean bulls
what does it mean genuinely
like
live round
how could that mean anything but bullet
you know
anyone know
people keep spamming that
all right well
[Music]
anyway i guess moving on nobody knows
live round also means a blank people say
a blank is missing the projectile part
of a bullet but
metal casing
yeah
blanks
okay who cares someone got shot i mean
what the [ __ ] do you want from me yeah
does it care what does it matter that
part doesn't really matter
i just don't know how you it there's no
way whatever i'm over it someone got two
people got shot
um yeah so brian laundry's corpse got
was found
and that the the
story is bizarre
his parents were the ones that found his
[ __ ] body they were and they found a
notebook there that had a suicide letter
or something some evidence his parents
found it yes his parents found his
backpack they also led the police to i
think that he called his parents and
told them that he was going to kill
himself and told them where
and then that's why the parents left i
mean this is just a theory
that makes sense yeah but yeah because
everyone always you know was theorizing
that the parents knew more than they
were letting on yeah because he was
there at their house and then
disappeared
but yeah they they found his backpack
the day that his parents decided to talk
to the police they found his body
yeah
but okay whatever
it's a whole sad affair
you know
yeah
so two bitched well one mystery resolved
the other one is born and anyway i just
want to watch the bachelorette on
tuesday
you know
we had a whole internal debate on the
bachelorette
there was this guy who came on the set
with notes
copious amounts of notes
saying this is how to this is how i
should act this is what i should say
here's how i maximize my screen time
explain that sam
he had notes on how to maximize his
screen time no olivia was defending him
oh you were defending him sorry sam
you're good explain that olivia
olivia and ian were defending this guy
saying that maybe that's just what he
does and takes notes then why does he
have notes on maximizing screen time
well
his ex-girlfriend
came out and said that google docs and
like writing intense notes is just his
thing like when they would go on
vacation well i don't take notes about
how to bury ela's body well also just
because i'm in the nose
i don't think
that it's super crazy going on a reality
show for the first time that's so crazy
where producers tend to want to make
people into villains
to like to just be prepared well it's
funny because in his notes he wrote how
not to be a villain and he immediately
became the victim i know
world record villain speed run i mean i
would definitely if i were the
bachelorette if i saw that i would be
like red flag but i'm not going to send
him home
you wouldn't
oh he'd be gone he's gone that's badly
sounded he had notes how to maximize
screen time definitely and he had like a
whole dossier on her personality and
[ __ ] it was creepy
that was kind of creepy this person in
the chat said hate to break it to you
guys the bachelor is scripted no it's
not no it's not you are not bachelor
nation
i'm sorry possible it's not true
try again what do you got inside info
sorry to break it to you but i'm
bachelor nation and i know
[ __ ] he just said he literally knows the
producer on an early season
okay bring him on come call in and then
all reality shows are scripted no
they're not
no they're not i can't i can only watch
it with it's the crew it's impossible
yeah it's both that's just like some
dumb [ __ ] how can it be
like they know okay all these people
would have to be like the best actors
what i think is possible is that they
plan beats for certain things to happen
right but the relationships and the
stuff and this and that's not a script
in the sense of like a movie script but
it is highly highly highly manipulated
what you see yeah it's manipulated for
sure i mean watching it for my enjoyment
which is fine these people
while we watch it we're always like wow
these producers are like insane and mean
yeah because they're clearly psychopaths
they're setting things up yeah they're
like the saw guy the producers oh yeah
no they're
but like you can't
it depends on what you're defining the
scripted
they don't yeah you're right they don't
sit down and write a script like you
would a television so you take it
nationally
it's not scripted but it is i think a
better way thing to say is uh
highly manipulated everybody knows that
i'm curious like flavor of love were
scripted where like a girl [ __ ] on the
floor
my
counter argument to
this being scripted is that first of all
this guy
let's take the girl sitting on the floor
for example she is not going to
volunteer to destroy her reputation be
lampooned by the whole world it's just
not this is that that one may have been
a real moment
or maybe maybe maybe not i haven't seen
it maybe it didn't even happen tell you
the truth who knows but i'm saying she's
now the girl who [ __ ] on the floor
around the world is not no amount of
money is worth it nobody's going to do
that sure agree to that same thing with
the notebook somebody's saying it's like
curb your enthusiasm i don't think so
because i feel like
world-renowned actors verb they actually
act you know they they also improvise
and they take it like a step
further like that the people in curb are
like world-class comedians and actors
these are not people off the craigslist
like these people on on bachelor are not
[ __ ] they're like nobodies
sorry also they're real people and
you know you can follow them on
instagram yeah that's what i was gonna
say that's such a huge commitment to
like be a character for the rest of your
life it's impossible it doesn't make any
sense this is just what people like to
say but it's not true trust me i'm
bachelor nation they've been on
instagram
you can see you go back a few months
they're working in like doing a normal
job they're not acting so you're telling
me that these people prepared to be on
this show
10 years in advance have a fake media
persona just to be on the bachelor for
one season now this guy who got caught
taking the notes is getting [ __ ]
dragged on social media
his life is ruined okay so many people
in the chat are saying that it's
scripted and you guys are wrong
definitions of scripted it's not maybe i
think we all believe the same it's not
scripted i think maybe the producers
will pull someone aside and be like this
person just said this about you how does
that make you feel of course
but that's obvious that's why i like it
that doesn't mean it's scripted it means
that the producers know what they're
doing
tv freaks to make the show entertaining
that's why i like it
these people are victims they're not
actors
like you guys yeah because you go you go
on reality shows to ruin your life
nobody escapes it they are victims
the allure of being famous even infamous
is uh very powerful to some people
that's all i'll say
i think that
you're saying like nobody would do that
because they it would ruin their life or
whatever i don't think they see it that
way necessarily
bro trust me right this guy with the
notepads he's out there trying to be the
next bachelor and he is [ __ ] like
everybody hates him and i know how bad
that feels because i've been on the
internet when everybody like hates you
for a minute and a normal person who's
not even used to that kind of scrutiny
it's not a good thing it's not a good
thing
i don't know they want us to do a portal
but you guys don't know what you're
talking about how many how many of you
actually watch it though
so true how many of you guys actually
watched right i'm back
you guys don't understand how deep i am
you think i'm dumb you think i couldn't
tell the difference
also if it's scripted what do you have
to say about all of the people who are
still married
if that's yeah oh right it's all fake
yeah people have been together and you
want to explain that
again i'm not saying that you're you
keep going back to like i'm saying the
entire thing's planned i i understand
that these are real people and that they
are really playing this game yeah and
i'm still gonna keep what you are seeing
on television is is far
far from what actually went down in the
vast majority i know that i know we're
saying the same thing okay but i don't
want to watch just people casually
dating no
but while we are saying all of this
people are saying you're wrong to us
paul i think people think that their
words are written for what is the poll
i don't think they don't
basically there's got we got to be clear
about this
it's manipulated we all know that so
let's say is it manipulated or is it 100
scripted
that's what i really don't think well
maybe some people do think that people
are saying that they're about bachelor
i mean sam you're back
what do you what's your takeaway
listen i don't care if it's scripted
it's the best show on earth wait don't
even say that don't give them no it's
okay okay no i don't think it's scripted
i it is definitely manipulated though
yeah yeah that's cool for sure should i
have a third option if it's like three
degrees it's real it's manipulated is it
scripted no
no because we all agree that it's
manipulated it would be boring if it
wasn't manipulated guys exactly we would
not be watching this
i'm team dan on this one guys i'm sorry
you
are watching all them yeah
i'm saying it's scripted to the degree
that dan's saying it's scripted okay i
already agree
on that okay
are you disagreeing with me what are we
disagreeing well you guys didn't agree
with me i'm sending out the poll dancing
it's fabulous he says it's 100 fake i
guess it's just we have different
definitions of fake
yeah like we 100 agree
okay i don't know why you have to
conquer and divide us
you're not even a bachelor niche bro man
you're all tripping i just i've seen a
decent amount of it uh look at the poll
so about 20 of peop of the audience says
it's 100 fake it's scripted and those 20
do not watch well they're wrong that
percentage is actually rising we're
getting close to 25 they're wrong
audiences the paul is manipulated
it's impossible
i think that the contestants are
amateurs they're they're not necessarily
actors although a lot of them are and
that's why they want to get on the show
sure of course um which you know actors
have outgoing personalities it's good
for the show anyways so i understand why
they oh yeah yes
but
and yeah but
they do things like if if something
happens if a fight happens it's
they stop recreate it a lot of the
things that you're seeing are is acting
because it wasn't caught on camera and
they want to make sure that it's seen
and so
they literally like oh say that to them
again you know
that happens but not like the really
like sometimes yeah sure i don't give a
[ __ ] i think some of the moments they
are visceral and real for sure but a lot
of it
uh i'm sure is kind of um
but hey you know the person to curb
wasn't actually that bad in the same way
they don't have a script there's nothing
like her
and they just and they just kind of
influence nothing like curve that's
insane
in the instances where they missed
something and they want to recreate it
that's just like we need you and
her to fight again but
it insinuates that the fight did happen
it just wasn't on camera right okay no i
don't think they re-fight i don't think
that happens i think something could
happen where they have like a tender
moment or say something funny and
they'll be like yo say that again fights
and stuff that's real that's raw
[Laughter]
and i'm offended at the insinuation
right
there's like a bunch of people that say
it's a bad poll and it's flipped what do
you want
i want them to get some reading
comprehension to be perfectly fine
this is a clear poll this is going to be
always some of these people are saying
bad pool they know how to read
how do we unflip it i want to get a
unflipped ball is the bachelor
manipulated or is it 100 scripted we
just had a giant conversation about the
difference between the two things if you
don't understand the difference between
those two i don't know what to say i
guess we can go 100 real
how about this how about this
i i just don't see the point of adding
100 real option because we know it's not
100 real i think we should uh we've got
a lot of people who watch this show
there's got to be one bachelor
whistleblower out there from abc right
like somebody yeah
it's been around for like 30 years and
you don't hear anybody you don't hear
this [ __ ] reality steve would be all
over it if he was totally fake because
nobody knows who's snaking information
to reality stephen
oh that's
sam made that for
bachelorette why
you guys do this on your free time sam
did she did it incredibly
that is so what beautiful
you want to tell us a little bit about
the spread
a little meat little cheese oh my god
which episode was this the premiere the
premiere yeah you got to go all out for
the premiere oh wow
god i came in she's like there's rose
petals everywhere she's looking all
frantic oh my god she takes a
professional sport
well
didn't she sort of win
the bachelor oh she's a bachelor mega
fan she entered true
weight before she won each three
bachelor
[Music]
[Applause]
oh she's a veteran right
you skirted the uh you're uh
you're one of the contestants that shows
up outside the compound from a previous
season like please i'm in love with her
i have uh i have a big revelation for
you guys right now in bombshell to drop
bombshell alert um the a3 bachelor was
rigged sam and ian were already dating
the entire thing was fake
uh it's scripted exactly based on what
you guys are saying you can't script
that that's what you that's what it
would mean based on what you guys are
saying it would mean that the ian and
sam situation would have been scripted
that was real as it gets and look where
it is now look at them they're still
together you're saying it's a script no
that's love
shame on you dad
don't buy it don't buy it people it was
too real to be in the comments for
example sometimes like what happened in
the previous season
was that the guy who won was a [ __ ]
plant
last season the donkey kong yeah the
donkey kong face guy
so they broke
he won the guy with the upside down face
dude that dudes that dude straight up
was donkey kong this guy you recognize
him
we me and eel didn't like him we thought
he had
bad intentions oh yeah i didn't like him
yeah his head is upside down
[Laughter]
his head is flipped he's flipped
he's hit he looks and he looks like
donkey kong he's just got a strange face
like i've never seen anyone that looks
like him crimson chin dude
he's probably got such a weak chin to
have that big ice beard it's probably
like tiny are they still together yeah
they're still together i think okay so
we're all wrong
i think so but they he was a plant from
a previous season now i think this
shit's all set up right they take him
they plant him in there he shows up and
he's like i'm in love and i want to get
in yeah but like everything that happens
after that is real and raw
yes
and they're still together to this day
so shame on you dan i mean sam would not
be putting out spreads like that if it
was scripted people were saying charcusi
[Music]
why because he looks like a shark oh my
god not a shark actually you said
sharkuzy sharkus
yeah why is shark though
sharks reborn
oh okay so i get them
okay
ethan you know we could get intel about
bachelor because do you know becca
martinez
oh yeah
she's a big fan of frenemies and
probably um us too she probably on
social side and also uh jacinia
who was on paradise oh yeah she's a huge
fan we should totally let's we gotta do
let's get
let's get well i think justinia is a
real like a real also i don't think
justinia is out of contract yet
so we may have to get back up because
she'll talk she'll she'll talk about
well becca's like straight bachelor she
was on this she was on a show she was on
paradise i'm telling you this shit's
real guys this is this is alumni there's
history deep roots yeah how [ __ ] shame
on you and shame on you a.b
right
jacenya was spotted wearing teddy fresh
right yeah she's she's a real she's a
real one
i tried i tried i give it a chance
yeah i'm with you on that amy i can't i
can't get into this you guys don't watch
i gave them lebanon
it was a good time i've now because
i i've i've been roped into watching two
seasons now the two most recent oh you
watched the full season pretty much
that's good what had you liked the last
one it was pretty good
the last one was the one with with dk
right yeah with donkey kong yeah i
really
he looks like donkey kong yeah since
pete the pilot i've been out that's a
horrible honestly that's he's yeah that
was that made me stop watching for a
little bit that was bad that guy was
such a [ __ ] such a bad but the last
bachelor in paradise three engagements
that's pretty crazy that is crazy i
didn't watch the paradise version
paradise is really good the last season
of paradise was the best season ever
yeah
i agree
um wait do you see the resemblance
the [ __ ] jaw and everything in the
hair it's easier to see when he's in
motion i feel like the photograph
doesn't fully um
i'm sorry oh donkey kong says trans
right so you see that
donkey kong is a trans icon he said
where the [ __ ] did you read that the one
with the trans flag at the bottom
i don't know the context of that but
okay
became a trans icon yeah
all right
i'll read that one later
not ready for all that
um
yeah i uh i somewhat enjoyed it the best
part
uh of that last time
well there were certain elements of it
that were very enjoyable the the girls
was it her mom and like aunt oh she was
such a horse
that was right
that was the best part
i don't know if we can it's abc they'll
probably claim us well i'll just remove
it then okay what is how are you going
to find that clip now oh i think it was
katie's
her name was katie why is abe lincoln
the bachelor cam what's the context here
oh cam thinks he looks similar to the
donkey kong dude
lincoln
i don't see it
sorry cam
can't take it back to the lab i can't
follow you on down on this one
uh hey olivia i was romantically talking
to a contestant from the bachelorette
that was in the top four on becca season
and and bachelor in paradise
love to talk about it i have pics
i'd rather just talk to the person not
like
you know what i mean
like i know a person that knows a person
that knows a person
any credentials people
yeah so
um you found that clip or should we just
not even show it i mean i think i found
this was part of it right where
this is it yeah so so blake meets
katie's mom and aunt and her aunt is the
nastiest person i have ever
seen ever it's just
our family because at the end of the day
you're here because we want you here not
because we need you here right
originally when i knew you were coming
on the show
it didn't dawn on me that you would be
or could be engaged at the end
i feel like there's enough time maybe if
you minimize it it will reduce the
chance of being clean like this yeah
nothing has to be
yeah
yeah we're not we're not about to get
married and have kids
but i think because we're both so
independent and have our own goals and
dreams
like we don't
need each other we've been able to live
our own life we want and yeah it's super
important not to need someone
you can survive on your own by the way
it's just positive
the premise is she's the bachelorette
he's in her top like three or four or
something or is actually maybe she was
even the last one because one of the
guys left
and um
so her family's coming to meet him with
the context that like she's supposed to
get engaged and they're just like we
don't it's like they just tore the whole
thing down i've never seen anything like
that it's a little back story
put ourselves in a position
where we have to rely on a male
that just this is we don't need no
motivation
if we invite you in you are so lucky
okay
marriage is a lot
yeah that's not all it's cracked up to
me no for sure and like
that's the thing is like i've lived
through it like i've lived through
watching my parents pick it up that's
not the same thing though right like
definitely but like watching a train
wreck is not the same as actually being
in that train wreck
right
yeah it's let's say marriage gets
something which i don't care no i didn't
watch the season
yeah this is so funny this was one of
the highlights yeah that was the first
oh that is so mean no it was hor it was
horrible i mean
and he was trying his best to be good
and be interested yeah i never seen
anything like she was just so mean go
ahead it keeps going
what's your plan
like how are you going to fix that
we katie and i have a thing going on
here and it's just
promising ourselves that we'll do
anything to make it right and keep
it yeah that's not how it works
don't like i mean cute but i mean
ultimately
anything works
you asked
and is that where you're at
like are you wanting to marry her
i don't know where you're gonna yell at
me again that lindsay was more hesitant
about
me and just kind of questioning
[Music]
what katie and i are and how we're going
to work through things and
all i could say was words to try and
reassure but it just seemed like nothing
i was saying was the right answer she
was looking for
so
what makes you want
the beard
oh my gosh
um they're still together by the way so
[ __ ] probably during our first date he
had talked about how he really is an
independent woman and how there's a time
where he could be gone for like a month
and he needs someone who can handle that
and i insulin is like
i got my own to do like that sounds like
the perfect
duo you guys are gonna
go your own way for
a month or two while he's in africa i
mean i mean that's a huge
uh like no matter what that's a huge
amount of time to be away from he's just
wants to be against how do you see that
ending
like
we're just going to make it work we just
don't know what that means yet if if
that means i go to canada then i'll go
you know if i get to go to africa
because i want to we'll go like
i'm like we really aren't worried i know
these are huge things to figure out but
that's what we want to do we want to
figure it out you just said if you need
to go to canada you will if you need to
go to africa you will like it it just
sounds like a lot of oh yes yes sir yeah
and really my question is how much is he
willing to put into your happiness
because the rest we don't care about if
something doesn't work yeah
good luck you know why is she here i
hate her are you ready to ask katie to
marry her
i just want to make sure that what i do
is right for for katie and i
and so you know i've got a lot of
thinking to do about it i just want to
make sure it's the right thing
what are the plans
are you moving in together also like all
stuff
they're just gonna date like they i
don't the one thing i think silly about
this show is like you're supposed to get
engaged at the end but ultimately you're
just dating like it doesn't mean
anything it's not that [ __ ] serious
but they are engaged for real now so
[ __ ] these love haters
was it like the mom and sister
yeah her it was her aunts or her mom's
sister mom and dad mom and dad we hate
men so we think you should be single
forever
you said you're gonna go to canada for
him that sounds like a yes sir yes sir
um
anyway bachelor nation forever
um the new season i don't know if you
guys heard it had the worst ratings of
any premiere by far
like dude the premiere had like 400 000
viewers
this show
has better ratings than the bash wait
google it i read it yeah i'm reading it
premiere low
what was the viewership they say it was
like [ __ ] abysmal do you think it's
chris harrison
no i think it's because they did the
back-to-back season yeah i think it's
the back to back and i think that
bachelorettes are just kind of boring
like i just i hate to say it because
they're nice i like them but like i
don't know it just doesn't excite me in
the pics
but i do think that um the hosting
situation is not horrible i don't
understand why there has to be two women
when there was just one man i agree it's
like you need two women to fill the role
yeah what the [ __ ] exactly it's like one
is not enough somehow that's so weird
it should just it's back to back to back
i can't keep eating charcuterie
[Music]
well i can never get enough i'll be
honest it was uh three million down from
last night three million last season hit
five
that's a huge
debt man
yeah i mean for
i mean that show
i thought was huge huge but
well not so much
anyway
that's all i have to say about that i
may not be a smart man
but i don't know what's [ __ ] up when i
see it
also watching the um the real house
lives um beverly hills it's the tell all
now there's like three of them but i
think i'm the only one right nobody here
i don't i'm even out on that show i
watched the lisa rinna part where she
talked about amelia and scott
it was interesting
i'm out on that real housewives [ __ ]
i can't [ __ ] with that
it's all about erica they're just so
annoying they're like the worst people
on earth all gathered just so rich
so freak disgusting out of touch just
god awful
yeah i mean if you were like talking
about class warfare and [ __ ] like that
and overthrowing all you have to do is
show
the real housewives of beverly hills
and uh uh class war is inevitable
i don't know if i made this joke before
but i'm pretty sure they show real
housewives of beverly hills to isis
recruitment uh centers so
i don't know
um well it's not as fun talking about it
where no one else is really involved
but i don't know i love it
i love that you love it
i'll make lena watch it with me
so we can talk about it
all right well
i guess that's it eh
zach keeps looking at me get me to say
something zach just say it say what you
want to say what's going on oh no we we
just
we're doing this crazy thing uh that we
thought you guys would enjoy so i'm
wondering if it's cool if we could try
it
go ahead
what is
zach was asking me dan he wants
permission to do the disco effect oh you
want a disco
you want a disco
all right you got to hit that move you
did though yeah this is the way we're
going to take out the show today this is
all right that's good actually
all right everybody ready
everybody ready disco yeah
i'm ready yeah love is ready this is it
i mean is there something
oh
hey we should give a seizure warning
probably
like on ironically
okay seizure warning is your warning if
you are epileptic please turn off the
stream
let's go
you gotta move fast and like
[Music]
there you go
oh
here get one avila
[Music]
there you go this one right here
[Music]
[Music]
now dan definitely looks like fear and
loathing with those glasses
all right now i'm starting to get willy
wonka tunnel freak vision
we don't know which way we're rowing
is it raining is it snowing
is a hurricane of blowing
but surely the fear must be growing
[Music]
all right guys that's about it for us
hey
good weekend
so we'll be back on sunday for the
leftovers
or tomorrow if you remember if you're a
member
become a member
anyway what's for uh lunch ela
i don't know do you have any dinner
thoughts i think elena is surprising us
with something oh i love that i love
that
love that
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wait wait do it on me because it's
really painful when i do this okay here
we go
oh
yeah
[Music]
all right i'm out of here
peace out peace out everybody
[Music]
you